Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 180. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und nach einer kurzen Pause hab ich mal wieder ein bisschen Material für euch und manche von euch kann ich auch beruhigen. Das geht heute mal nicht um Programmiersprachen. Aber trotzdem geht es natürlich hier um Technik und zwar mal wieder so ein Thema, wo meine heimliche Untertitel Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft mal wieder ganz gut zusammenkommt, wie ich finde. Tatsächlich auch ein Thema, was ich hier ansatzweise schon mal gehabt habe vor drei Jahren, Chaosradio Express 75 mit dem Titel Energiespar-Häuser, Gespräch mit Ron über sein frisch gebautes Haus und welche Erfahrungen er da so gemacht hat. Und das Feedback auf diese Sendung war ziemlich erstaunlich. Also ich habe mich über die Jahre immer wieder gewundert, wie viele Leute da drauf mich angesprochen haben und das irgendwie spannend und interessant fanden. Und von daher hatte ich auch schon lange auf meiner Liste da mal so eine kleine Fortsetzung bzw. auch Ergänzung zu machen, weil es sich ja dabei auch nur um ein Energiespar-Haus gehandelt hat und eben auch nur um eines. Na ja, und heute wollen wir den Bogen mal ein bisschen weiter spannen und so die gesamte Welt der Energiespar-Problematik rund ums Bauen und Häuser und Wohnen etc. aufziehen, bis hin zu den sogenannten Passivhäusern. Ja, und dazu bin ich jetzt nach Darmstadt gefahren und freue mich, begrüßen zu können. Marc Großklos, hallo. Hallo. Und wir sind hier und du bist auch hier, du arbeitest hier im IWU, im Institut Wohnen und Umwelt.
Genau.
GmbH. Was ist denn das für ein... Also ist es ein Institut oder eine GmbH? Beides. Das klingt ja aber so ganz verdichtig.
Ja, wir sind eine gemeinhilfige Forschungseinrichtung vom Land Hessen und der Stadt Darmstadt und wir haben mehrere Themen Schwerpunkte. Dazu gehört Wohnungsversorgung, Mietspiegel, Verbesserung der Wohnungssituation aller möglichen Gruppen von der Bevölkerung. Das ist sozusagen der eine Hauptbereich, der andere Bereich beschäftigt sich mit Energieeinsparung in Gebäuden und da bin ich beschäftigt.
Und was ist so dein eigentlicher persönlicher Hintergrund? Hast du mal ein Studium abgeschlossen oder so?
Ja, das habe ich auch. Ich habe Energie- und Umweltschutztechnik studiert. Ich habe damals mich schon intensiv mit regenerativen Energien, mit Solartechnik, Brennstoffzellen und auch mit Energieeinsparungen in Gebäuden beschäftigt. Ich habe nach dem Studium so zwei Jahre in kleineren Büros Arbeiten rund ums Energieeinsparen abgelegt und bin jetzt seit 1996 hier im Institut.
Und was ist dann hier so konkret deine Aufgabe?
Einer meiner Schwerpunkte sind Modellprojekte, wo wir Energiespar-Konzepte, neue Gebäude oder auch nur einzelne Techniken in der Praxis erproben. Wir beraten oder ich berate auch Architekten oder Bauherren bei der Konzeption von besonders energiesparenden Gebäuden. Ja, und dann wollen wir natürlich im Endeffekt auch wissen, ob die denn so funktionieren, wie ursprünglich gedacht. Das ist dann fast noch der spannende Teil, denn da wohnen ja dann Menschen drin, die sich vielleicht anders verhalten, wie ursprünglich geplant.
Hier wird ja auch gerade ganz fleißig gebaut. Wir stehen hier auch unter permanenter Bedrohung durch Unterbrechungen oder Störungen von Baulärm. Das ist aber jetzt hier kein Neubau, sondern hier wird saniert.
Ja, genau. Das Gebäude ist auch schon fast 50 Jahre alt, war früher ein normales Büroverwaltungsgebäude und wurde jetzt mit Passivhauskomponenten energetisch saniert, wie man das nennt. Also es wurde die Gebäudehülle gedämmt, das Dach, die Außenwand haben ein Wärme-Dämmverbundsystem bekommen, unter der Kellerdecke kamen nochmal 12 cm Dämmung, neue Fenster, Passivhausfenster, die auch den Schallschutz verbessern sollten, denn wir liegen hier direkt an einer stark befallenen Straße und zusätzlich eben eine Lüftungsanlage, die für frische Luft sorgt und dafür auch sorgt, dass wir die Fenster nicht aufmachen müssen zur Straßenseite hin.
Also kein komplettes Passivhaus, aber sozusagen so Sanierungen mit Best-Effort-Ansatz.
Genau, der Ansatz bei diesen Sanierungen mit Passivhauskomponenten ist ein Heizwärmebedarf von 25 Kilowattstunden pro Quadratmeter um ein Jahr zu erreichen. Passivhaus im Neubaustandard wären 15 Kilowattstunden und erreicht haben wir hier diese 15 Kilowattstunden fast. Also wir liegen zwischen 16 und 17 Kilowattstunden. Also schon erstaunlich guter Wert.
Aber bevor wir so konkret auf sowas eingehen, wie weit muss man denn so in die Geschichte zurückblicken, wenn man so die Anstrengungen Energie zu sparen? Also wo kann man denn so die ersten Bewegungen sehen, dass man überhaupt über sowas Gedanken gemacht hat?
Also bekannt sind ja die Hypochaustenheizungen von den Römern, die im Prinzip zweischalige Wände hatten.
Hypochausten.
Hypochausten. Wo warme Luft durch die Wand geleitet wurde, um Gebäude zu erwärmen. Das haben sie natürlich am liebsten bei ihren Bädern genutzt, aber auch bei etwas vornehmenden Gebäuden. Das waren aber nicht die ersten. Man hat nördlich von Frankfurt in der Wetterau eine Siedlung ausgegraben. Ich glaube, das war die Zeit vor dem Kälten noch. Vor 3.000, 3.500 Jahren haben die gelebt. Und aufgrund von Pfostenlöchern in der Erde konnte man rekonstruieren, wie die Außenwände damals aufgebaut waren. Und man hat natürlich keine konkreten Reste gefunden, aber es zeigte sich, dass die Außenwände im Prinzip zweischalig waren. Also Holzpfosten dazwischen waren dann verschiedene Materialien eingebracht, die auch eine Dämmwirkung haben. Und es gibt eine Rekonstruktion dieser Wand. Und wenn man mal ausrechnet, was für ein Wärmeverlust diese Wand hat, da sind zum Beispiel so ungefähr 10 cm Stroh drin gewesen. Und dieser U-Wert, wie man das heutzutage ausdrückt, der liegt ungefähr in der gleichen Ordnung wie das, was vor 15 Jahren mit der Wärmeschutzverordnung als gesetzlicher Mindeststandard in Deutschland eingeführt wurde.
Ach, U-Wert, wo steht denn das U?
Das ist der Wärmedurchgangskoeffizient der Wand. Das wird eben auf U...
U, man hat einfach einen Buchstaben genommen, der ja auch noch frei war.
Genau. Und das ist eben eine Kenngröße für den Wärmeverlust eines Quadratmeters Wand- oder Bauteils pro Kelvin-Temperatur-Differenz.
Das heißt, die Kelten haben schon nach der Wärmeschutzverordnung gebaut?
Nee, sie haben wahrscheinlich eher intuitiv festgestellt, wenn ich da ein bisschen mehr Stroh reinmache und mehr dämme, dann ist es im Winter wärmer. Brauche ich weniger Holz zu sammeln, habe ich was gewonnen.
Braucht man weniger Energie, um es warm zu kriegen?
Genau.
Pfiffig. Und die Römer haben es gleich für ihren Luxus missbraucht und dann die Sauna entsprechend ausgerüstet?
Die haben ja dann auch nicht nur für ihre Schiffe, sondern auch eben für ihren Wohlstand halb Afrika oder halb Nordafrika abgeholzt. Und irgendwann hatten die da ein Problem, weil es eben auch keine Bäume mehr gab. Und danach lässt sich das ein bisschen schwieriger nachvollziehen. Also im Mittelalter war Holz eigentlich meistens das große Problem. Es wurde ja auch zum Beispiel für Bergwerke in großen Mengen dann verfeuert. Von daher haben die Leute einfach anders gelebt als wahrscheinlich ein großes Teil der Reichenrömer. Und auf jeden Fall auch anders gelebt, als wir es heutzutage tun. Es gibt auch Untersuchungen in einem Freilichtmuseum, ich glaube in Klappenburg, da hat man mal so ein Scheunenhaus beheizt, so wie es vor ein paar hundert Jahren auch genutzt wurde. Man hat festgestellt, dass die Raumtemperatur da nur so vier, fünf Grad über der Außentemperatur lag. Mehr war nicht möglich, einfach weil die Gebäude so undicht waren und man eben auch nicht so viele Feuer in einem Holzgebäude da einbringen wollte. Von daher waren die Menschen früher auch gewöhnt, ganz andere Temperaturen zu ertragen im Winter.
Das heißt, hätte man dann schon so gebaut wie die Kelten, hätte das schon besser ausgesehen.
Ja, aber dieses Wissen ist dann eben teilweise verloren gegangen. Wobei man hat sich im Prinzip das gleiche Konstruktionsprinzip auch weiterhin zu Nutze gemacht. Dadurch, dass zum Beispiel bei den Fachwerkhäusern ist ja zwischen den Holzpfosten eine Lehm-Ausfachung. Und dieser Lehm wurde zusätzlich noch mit Stroh abgemagert. Und das führte neben Materialansparung auch dazu, dass die Wärmedämmung dieser Gefache verbessert wurde. Also man kann schon erkennen, dass die Menschen immer versucht haben, Energie einzusparen und dadurch auch ein behagliches Klima in ihren Gebäuden zu erreichen.
Beziehungsweise überhaupt erst mal auf eine Temperatur zu kommen, die man als angenehm empfinden kann, ohne jetzt sind uns immer mit der Energie zusammen, die man eben noch alternativ aufbringen muss. Ja, Fachwerkhäuser, das heißt Fachwerkhäuser sind eigentlich schon mal ganz pfiffiges Bauprinzip. Kann man das so sagen?
Ja, Fachwerkshäuser sind eigentlich Gebäude, die gebaut wurden dort, wo keine Steine vorhanden waren, weil es schwierig war, die abzubauen oder man muss so weit transportieren. Und man brauchte natürlich die großen Stämme, um jetzt die Holzkonstruktion zu errichten. Aber den Rest, den konnte man dann meistens mit regionalen Materialien auch decken. Und ja, wie gesagt, wenn man da nicht zu viel, aber ausreichend Stroh zugemischt hat, dann wurde es auch nicht so kalt im Gebäude.
Und die Römer haben sich ja so einiges einfallen lassen, was so heutzutage immer wieder erstaunt ist. Ich habe in Beileibe keinen guten Überblick. Aber inwiefern ist denn dieses Wissen, also wie ist denn dieses konkrete Wissen der Römer erhalten geblieben? Man hat ja das Gefühl, so vieles war da alles schon mal und dann ist erst mal tausend Jahre lang wieder nichts passiert.
Genau, diesen Eindruck habe ich auch.
Hätten sie mal eine Webseite aufsetzen sollen. Ja, und gut, jetzt ist es ja so, irgendwann, ich weiß nicht, kann man das konkret datieren, also zumindest so Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts, das ging genau genommen schon im 19. Jahrhundert los, also irgendwann hatte man so ein bisschen den Bogen raus, wie man so größere Energiemengen überbauen machen konnte. Entweder indem man halt gnadenlos abgeholzt hat und gibt ihm, bis nichts mehr zu holen war. Aber dann halt so mit so Energiesteigerungen, wie Kohle natürlich schon seit Langem, aber dann irgendwann natürlich auch so die Ausbeutung des Öls. Da hatte man wieder so ein Reservoir, was irgendwie unendlich zu sein schien. Und man hat irgendwie so ein bisschen quasi die Wärme auf dem anderen Weg erzeugt. Man hat einfach mehr Energie genommen, weil war ja genug da.
Genau, und das kam noch gleichzeitig dieses Wachstum dazu. Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts sind ja die Städte überall in Deutschland oder zumindest mal eigentlich überall in Europa deutlich gewachsen. Es gab eben diese Kohle hauptsächlich als Heizmaterial. Und auch durch dieses schnelle Wachstum hat man jetzt da weniger darauf geachtet, auch die Gebäude so zu bauen, dass sie wenig Energie verbrauchen. Es gab dann mal in den 20er-Jahren so eine Zwischenphase, da hat man, glaube ich, auch relativ bekannt in Berlin. Da gibt es eine spezielle zweischalige Wandkonstruktion, die dann auch dazu geführt hat, dass eigentlich ältere Gebäude aus dieser Zeit weniger Energie verbrauchen als jetzt zum Beispiel die Nachkriegsgebäude. Die wurden einfach nur schnell hochgezogen, damit möglichst viele Leute wieder ein Dach über dem Kopf hatten. Und da hat man sich überhaupt keine Gedanken drum gemacht. Man hat einfach die Trümmer der zerstörten Städte genommen, daraus neue Steine geformt und damit Häuser gebaut. Und die hatten natürlich ein paar sozusagen Lufteinschlüsse auch mit drin, was die Wärmedämmung ein bisschen verbessert hat. Aber da war natürlich jetzt kein Energiekonzept dahinter.
Was sind denn nun eigentlich die Konzepte? Also muss man jetzt möglichst viel Luft in die Wand bringen? Ist das im Prinzip schon das ganze Lied?
Luft hilft, aber sie muss richtig dosiert sein. Denn die Luft dämmt nur dann gut, wenn sie in möglichst kleine Hohlräume eingeschlossen ist und sich nicht viel bewegen kann. Wenn ich also jetzt einen großen Hohlraum habe, dann gibt es da Konvektionsströmungen drin und das verschlechert dann wieder die Wärmedämmung.
Aber so haben es auch die Kelten gemacht. Das war jetzt einfach nur so zwei Wände und Luft dazwischen, oder?
Nein, da war ja das Stroh dazwischen. Und je nachdem, wie dick, fest man dieses Stroh dann auch gestampft hat, wurden die Zwischenräume relativ klein. Also die Luft konnte sich nicht bewegen. Und das Stroh hat sich dann auch nur punktuell berührt. Das heißt, es gibt ja drei Mechanismen jetzt bei der Wärmeübertragung über so eine Wand. Also einerseits die Wärmeleitung durch Material von innen nach außen. Das wäre dann zum Beispiel über die Strohhalme. Dann gibt es die Konkurrenz.
Oder durchs Mauerwerk selber halt.
Ja gut, man guckt sich das dann sozusagen sehr mikroskopisch an. Und dann ist dann bei den Kelten war es das Stroh. Heutzutage sind es dann die Steinpartikel in den Hohlblocksteinen, zum Beispiel, die dann zu einer Wärmeleitung führen. Da sind aber heutzutage zum Beispiel noch ganz viele kleine Lufteinschlüsse drin, die aber nicht so groß sein dürfen. Sonst gibt es eben diese Konvektionsströmungen im Stein oder in der Konstruktion.
Was heißt dann zu groß? Nicht zu groß, also wie groß?
Je kleiner, desto besser. Ideal wäre, wenn sich die eingeschlossenen Luftmoleküle überhaupt nicht mehr bewegen können. Bewegen schon, aber nicht mehr das nächste Luftmolekül treffen können. Denn nur durch dieses Anstoßen des nächsten Luftmoleküls wird ja die Wärme eigentlich übertragen. Wenn das sozusagen im Vakuum sich ein bisschen bewegt, das führt nicht zu einer Wärmeübertragung. Genau dieses Prinzip macht man sich heutzutage ja auch bei der Vakuumdämmung zu nutzen.
Das wollte ich jetzt gerade fragen. Also idealerweise hat man gar keine Luft.
Genau. Gar keine Luft funktioniert technisch leider nicht so besonders gut. Deswegen versucht man, möglichst viel Luft aus einem solchen Vakuumdämpfpanel abzupumpen. Es bleiben aber immer noch Luftmoleküle drin. Die sind in ganz kleinen Hohlräumen eingeschlossen. Und die Hohlräume sind idealerweise so klein, dass das Luftmolekül nicht das nächste findet, um durch Stöße Wärme-Energie austauschen zu können.
Das ist ja schon sehr klein. Da reden wir ja schon ein bisschen mehr von Mauer-Schaum.
Wir reden hier eigentlich schon vom Mikrometer- und vielleicht auch Nanometerbereich.
Das heißt, der ideale Baustoff sieht aus wie ein Steinblock? Ist aber zur Hälfte Luft und die Hälfte ist aber so verteilt, dass man gar nicht merkt, dass da irgendwo Lufteinschlüsse sind. Sieht aus wie ein massiver Block.
Vakuumdämmung ist da sicherlich sozusagen die Hightech-Variante. Klassisch jetzt bei modernen Gebäuden, wenn man eine Außendämmung aufbringt aus Polystyrol oder einem anderen Kunstharz-Schaum, da wird Luft in möglichst kleine Partikel eingeschlossen, sodass sie sich eben nicht bewegen kann. Und wenn eben diese Zellen, in denen die Luft eingeschlossen ist, wenn die zusammengebacken werden, zum Beispiel zu einem Dämpf-Lok, dann kann man das relativ gut handhaben. Man hat also viel eingeschlossene Luft mit wenig Material außenrum, weil diese Zellen, die haben nur ganz dünne Wände.
Aber jetzt mal bei diesen Mauersteinen.
Bei Mauersteinen versucht man das.
Das ist ja kein Vakuum im eigentlichen Sinne.
Nee, Vakuum gibt es auch nur bei den eigentlichen Vakuum-Isolationspanelen.
Ich meine jetzt, die normalen Mauersteine, die sozusagen die ideale Verhältnis zwischen Stein und Luft haben, wie stellt man das her?
Da wird dann zum Beispiel ein Material zugegeben, das beim Brennen des Steins sich auflöst, es wandelt sich in Gas um und dadurch entstehen kleine Poren. Und diese Poren werden dann beim Erkalten des Steins sozusagen fest eingefroren.
Das heißt, das Gas verbleibt eigentlich oder wandelt sich das in irgendwas anderes um?
Das können im Prinzip Partikel sein, die dann einfach verbrennen. Bei einer Verbrennung entsteht einfach Gas. Und dieses Gas kann aber nicht entweichen, sondern es bildet kleine Bläschen dann.
Da ist aber keine Luft, sondern da ist schon überwiegend was Ungiftiges. Nicht, dass man auf so einen Stein draufhaut und dann fängt er an zu explodieren oder so.
Hab ich noch nicht erlebt.
Du musst ja an alles denken. Um nochmal so auf die Ausgangsfrage zurückzukommen, das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen jetzt erst mal so die Kernschlussfolgerung aus der Materialforschung und Energieforschung, dass wenn man so eine Umantelung eines Wohnbereiches oder Arbeitsbereiches baut, ein Haus, dass man eben zusieht, dass die eigentliche Trennwand nach außen möglichst viel Luft enthält, aber diese wiederum so klein wie irgendwie möglich, damit sie zwar isoliert, aber eben in keiner Form zu irgendeinem Wärmeaustausch beiträgt.
Das muss nicht unbedingt Luft sein. Es gibt auch Materialien, die andere Gase enthalten, Kohlendioxid zum Beispiel. Oder es gibt eben auch Konzepte, wo man massive Materialien nimmt, zum Beispiel ein Ziegel, und in Hohlräume dazwischen packt man dann aber wieder andere Dämpfstoffe rein.
Das ist zum Beispiel Stroh, das haben wir bei den Kelten.
Strohhäuser gibt es auch. Da nimmt man allerdings dann üblicherweise 50-60 Zentimeter dicke Strohballen. Die sind allerdings eher ein bisschen exotisch, aber ist auch eine interessante Technik.
Kann man machen, nimmt aber wiederum viel Platz ein. 50er-, 60er-Jahre, klar, gerade in Deutschland wieder auf Bau, da gab es ein anderes Thema. Wann kann man festmachen, woran sich so eine Energierevolution entwickelt hat? War das jetzt schon die Ölkrise in den 70er-Jahren?
Genau. In den 70er-Jahren hat man angefangen, sich da noch mal verstärkt Gedanken drum zu machen, wie man den Energieverbrauch reduzieren könnte. Und man kann auch sehen, da gab es eine ganze Reihe von Forschungsprojekten, wo dann auch von Seiten der Regierung die Entwicklung von neuen Techniken gefördert wurde. Da gab es zum Beispiel in Aachen das Philips Experimentierhaus. Das war ein freistehendes Einfamilienhaus, da hat niemand drin gewohnt. Das war nach dem damaligen Stand der Technik relativ fortschrittlich, was Isolation angeht. Sie hatten, glaube ich, auch eine Lüftungsanlage drin. Und haben dann aber simuliert, wie sich denn die Menschen da drin verhalten. Es ging Glühlampen an, um jetzt die Situation darzustellen, dass jetzt jemand ins Wohnzimmer kommt und dort Fernseh guckt zum Beispiel. Dieses Gebäude hat man zum Beispiel verwendet, um Berechnungsprogramme zu evaluieren, die man auch in der Zeit angefangen hat zu entwickeln, um überhaupt vorhersagen zu können, wie viel Energie braucht denn, wird ein Gebäude denn benötigen.
Das heißt, das Haus war jetzt noch gar nicht so sehr im Hinblick auf Energiesparen gebaut worden, sondern es ging erstmal nur darum, messen zu können, was überhaupt für Energie anfällt und wie die...
Ja, beides. Man wollte ausprobieren, was ist erreichbar, und umgekehrt natürlich auch überprüfen, wie kann ich das zukünftig vorhersagen.
Und was hat man dann so für Ergebnisse daraus ziehen können?
Dass sowohl die Dämmung, die Wärmeverluste reduziert, man hat auch festgestellt, dass die Fenster zu einem nicht unwesentlichen Teil zur Energiebilanz von so einem Gebäude beitragen, wenn sie die Sonnenstrahlen einfangen und damit passiv Wärme gewinnen. Und das war wahrscheinlich auch ein sehr früher Versuch, in einem Wohngebäude in Deutschland eine mechanische Lüftungsanlage zu integrieren, sodass man den Luftaustausch nicht unkontrolliert entweder über Undichtigkeiten oder über offene Fenster herstellt, sondern man kann vorher festlegen, ich möchte jetzt zum Beispiel pro Stunde die Luft hier ein halbmal austauschen. Also alle zwei Stunden ist das Luftvolumen dieses Raumes komplett erneuert. Das ist sozusagen ohne mechanische Unterstützung gar nicht möglich, weil ich das gar nicht abschätzen kann. Das hängt auch eben von der Außentemperatur ab.
Das ist ja sozusagen ein Grunddilemma des Wohnhauses, dass man ja, man könnte zwar alles zumachen und isolieren, aber dann würde man ja ersticken. Und deswegen wird halt immer viel gelüftet, dann steht das Fenster die ganze Zeit offen. Das ist natürlich nicht gerade die optimale Isolierung, wenn man Fenster offen hat. Genau. Und wann hat sich da so eine richtige Bewegung draus gemacht? Ich meine, wer hat denn dieses Experiment durchgeführt?
Das war eben von der Firma Philips damals. Die hatten offensichtlich noch eine Forschungsabteilung und die haben überlegt, was gibt es da an neuen Konzepten.
Aber die haben jetzt nicht nur für sich geforscht, sondern die haben diese Ergebnisse auch veröffentlicht.
Genau, das ist publiziert worden. Im Anschluss gab es dann auch etliche Ansätze, wo man versucht hat, Energiespar-Konzepte jetzt zum Beispiel aus USA zu übernehmen. Da gab es auch ein größeres Forschungsprojekt, das hieß damals Landstuhlprojekt. Da wurden überwiegend Gebäude mit großen Glasflächen nach Süden gebaut, weil das in den USA, in den strahlungsreichen Regionen, da relativ gut funktioniert hat. Das hat in Deutschland auch leitlich funktioniert, meines Wissens, aber eben nicht zu so Energieeinsparungen geführt, wie man sich das eigentlich erwünscht hätte.
Obwohl es natürlich grundsätzlich schon sinnvoll ist, auch so etwas mit zu berücksichtigen.
Das muss auf jeden Fall mit berücksichtigt werden. Das ist eigentlich auch heutzutage ein Teil der Planungsphase von einem Gebäude, um zu gucken, wie viel passive Solarenergie kann ich da nutzen. Und danach, oder vielleicht auch ein bisschen zeitgleich, gab es noch die Entwicklung, dass man geguckt hat, was wir denn eigentlich in den skandinavischen Ländern an Techniken im Hausbau eingesetzt, um den Energieverbrauch zu reduzieren. Die haben ja eigentlich ein kälteres Klima und haben deswegen weniger auf die Solarenergienutzung gesetzt, sondern mehr auf die Reduktion der Wärmeverluste. Also die haben die Häuser einfach dicker eingepackt. Die hatten damals eben auch schon Lüftungsanlagen teilweise. Und es gab eine ganze Reihe von Gebäuden, die dann mehr oder weniger nach schwedischen oder dänischen Vorlagen in Deutschland gebaut wurden. Und da waren offensichtlich die Ergebnisse so, wie man es eigentlich auch erwartet hätte. Das hat nämlich dann dazu geführt, dass immer mehr Niedrigenergiehäuser gebaut wurden, wie man das damals genannt hat. Also Gebäude, die deutlich weniger Heizenergie verbrauchen als das, was jetzt als gesetzliche Mindestanforderungen damals galt.
Wobei die gesetzlichen Mindestanforderungen jetzt auch nicht so nahenlos waren.
Wie wir ja vorhin bei dieser präkältischen Wand gesehen haben.
Im Prinzip war das ja der Wandel, der überhaupt erst mal stattfinden müsste in den Köpfen, dass man sich da überhaupt Gedanken gemacht hat. Weil es auch immer alles noch so ein bisschen von diesem ewigen Wachstum und der unerschöpflichen Energiequellen geprägt war. Und Klimaeffekte etc. sowieso noch keiner diskutiert hat. Das heißt, man kann sagen, in den 70er Jahren aus so einer frühen Forschung heraus hat sich das so vermutlich in den 80er Jahren ohnehin mit der gesamten Umweltbewegung, zumindest in Deutschland, hat sich dann quasi auch schon so eine eigene Industrie, vielleicht der falsche Begriff, aber zumindest so eine eigene Bewegung entwickelt, die das vorangetrieben hat.
Also ich glaube Bewegung ist der richtige Ausbruch. Es waren wahrscheinlich nicht so besonders viele. Ich habe es ja damals noch nicht wirklich so selbst miterlebt.
Alles Hippies, die mit den Grasdächern und so.
Genau, das war auch in dieser Zeit sehr awoke und man hat es ausprobiert. Ich meine, auch das ist ein Versuch, die Wärmeverluste auch zu reduzieren. Neben dem ökologischen Aspekt, da hat man eben festgestellt, dass es funktioniert, es hat einen Einfluss, aber es gibt andere Techniken, die da vielleicht effektiver sind. Nichtsdestotrotz sind Grasdächer natürlich schöne Sachen.
Aber man hat zumindest überhaupt erst mal angefangen zu experimentieren.
Genau, das ist das Entscheidende. Es gab Bauherren, es gab Architekten, die angefangen haben, sich Gedanken darum zu machen und das Ganze verbessern wollten. Und das ist eben das Wichtigste.
Und kann man jetzt irgendwie sagen, dass es dann irgendwann auch so einen durchbruch gegeben hat? Oder steht der noch bevor?
Ja, das mit dem Durchbruch ist immer eine Frage der Perspektive. Zu Beginn der 90er Jahre gab es dann durchaus schon eine ganze Reihe von Projekten mit Niedrige-Energie-Häusern. Da hatten wir hier in Hessen auch, gab es ein Förderprogramm sogar, die wurden dann auch überprüft, ob sie auch das erreicht haben, was ursprünglich auch mal prognostiziert war an Energieverbrauch. Das waren, glaube ich, damals 30 Gebäude allein in Hessen. Und in anderen Bundesländern gab es eben ähnliche Konzepte. Und diese Erkenntnisse sind dann eben immer mehr auch in die gesetzlichen Vorgaben eingeflossen, weil man eben gesehen hat, ursprünglich wusste man gar nicht, wie man zum Beispiel 12 cm Wärmedämmung anbringen kann an einem Gebäude. Da gab es vielleicht mal vier oder fünf Zentimeter. Und im Laufe dieser Versuche wurden eben auch die Techniken und die Materialien weiterentwickelt. Die Hersteller sind eben zunehmend auch auf diesen Zug aufgesprungen. Das ist ja in Deutschland auch nicht so einfach. Man kann nicht einfach irgendein Material einsetzen am Gebäude, sondern normalerweise braucht es eine Zulassung beim Deutschen Institut für Bautechnik. Erst dann kann es sozusagen jeder Architekt verbauen, ohne eine aufwändige Zulassung zu beantragen. Das sind alles so diese formalen Voraussetzungen, die erfüllt sein müssen, um in der Entwicklung in Gang zu kriegen. Aber parallel gab es dann sozusagen noch den Versuch, über das Niedrigenergiehaus noch deutlich hinauszugehen und den Heizwärmebedarf so weit zu reduzieren, dass ich eigentlich gar keine Heizungskörper mehr benötige im Gebäude. Das ist dann der Ansatz des Passivhauses. Das war auch eigentlich schon Ende der 80er-Jahre. Das erste Passivhaus wurde, glaube ich, 1992 bezogen. Das steht auch hier in Darmstadt. Und der Wolfgang Feist, der das damals entwickelt hat, der hat aufbauend auf Erfahrung aus Skandinavien versucht, alle Einflussfaktoren auf den Heizwärmebedarf eines Gebäudes so zu optimieren, dass man die Heizwärme, die immer noch benötigt wird, über die Zuluft zuführen kann. Diese Gebäude haben auf jeden Fall eine Lüftungsanlage mit Wärmerückgewöhnung, um auch die Lüftungswärmeverluste zu reduzieren, hatten wir vorhin schon mal. Und wenn der Heizwärmebedarf niedrig genug ist, dann ist es auch möglich, über die Zuluft zu beheizen. Und das war so ein bisschen der Ansatz auch für den Namen Passivhaus. Also man braucht kein aktives Heizsystem. Heiz werden sie trotzdem noch, aber der Energieverbrauch dieser Gebäude liegt zum Beispiel jetzt nur noch bei ungefähr einem Zehntel dessen, was Gebäude eben normalen Bestand haben. Also eine sehr, sehr hohe Reduktion des Heizwärmebedarfs.
Also, kurz gesagt, Niedrige Energiehäuser waren überhaupt erstmal, wir kümmern uns überhaupt erstmal darum, dass irgendwas besser wird. Und es waren wahrscheinlich dann erstmal so die wichtigen Maßnahmen, dass man Doppelfenster nimmt, wo dann auch nochmal so eine Luftschicht zwischen zwei Scheiben ist, dass da eben nicht so viel Wärme entweichen kann oder vielleicht sogar drei Scheiben. Ich weiß nicht, was so der Stand der Dinge ist. Was baut man so ein für Fenster in solche Häuser?
Also bei Niedrige Energiehäusern können Zweifachverglasungen mit zwei Scheiben, die reichen da üblicherweise noch aus. Passivhäuser brauchen eine Dreifachverglasung und auch dann in speziellen Fensterrahmen, die auch nochmal extra gedämmt sind. Es hat sich aber auch gezeigt, dass die Preise der Fenster durch die höheren Absatzzahlen deutlich gesunken sind. Natürlich ist ein Dreifachverglas das Fenster immer noch teurer als ein Zweifachverglas, weil einfach auch mehr Material verbaut wird. Aber da sind die Preise sehr nach unten gegangen, sodass heute auch viele Renovierungen mit Dreifachverglasungen schon durchgeführt werden.
Ich habe im Ohr noch der einfache Weg, ich habe jetzt ein Haus mit einer schlechten Energiebilanz, jetzt baue ich mir mal tolle Fenster ein, da dann zwar tatsächlich erst mal die Heizlosten gesenkt hat, aber dann andere Probleme kamen, weil auf einmal nicht die, ich weiß nicht, die Feuchtigkeit, glaube ich, nicht richtig entweichen konnte und dann hat man Probleme mit dem Mauerwerk bekommen und Schwämme und keine Ahnung, was sich dann alles da abgesetzt hat. Das ist schon so einfach, ist es nicht, dass man jetzt einfach nur die Fenster austauscht und dann ist es besser.
Genau, also man muss sich das schon genau überlegen, denn physikalisch ist es so, gerade jetzt früher bei den Einfachverglasungen war die Fensterscheibe im Prinzip ein Kondensator, die komplette Feuchtigkeit des Raumes ist an der Einfachverglasung auskondensiert und meistens hat man unten noch so eine Rinne gehabt, wo dann eben das ganze Kondenswasser sich gesammelt hat und dann ist man irgendwie einmal am Tag mit dem Lappen vorbei gegangen und hat das trocken gewischt. Das war sozusagen die Trocknung des Raumes.
Das fällt dann einfach weg.
Wenn ich jetzt natürlich ein gutes Fenster habe, dann kondensiert da keine Feuchtigkeit mehr aus. Zusätzlich kommt dazu, dass das Fenster auch dichter ist. Es hat Gummidichtungen, um eben den ungewollten Luftaustausch zu reduzieren. Die Konsequenz ist natürlich, wenn ich ein Fenster austausche, aber an der Wand nichts ändere, also die nicht dämme, dann ist die Wand in der Folge dann kälter als das Fenster. Und meistens treten diese Probleme jetzt noch nicht mal an der normalen, glatten Außenwand auf, sondern in der Fensterleibung. Da muss man zum Beispiel aufpassen, dass man...
Leibung ist das, was das Fenster hält?
Genau, das ist sozusagen der Wandanteil innen oder außen, der da eben noch vor oder hinter dem Fenster ist. Und das muss auf jeden Fall, wenn ich eine Außendämmung aufbringe, auch mitgedämmt werden, sonst ist es bauphysikalisch, kann es einfach problematisch sein.
Das ist sozusagen die Lektion, die man daraus gezogen hat, dass, wenn man jetzt ein altes Haus sanieren möchte, ohne es jetzt vielleicht komplett umzubauen, dann muss man auf jeden Fall an den Fenstern was verbessern, weil das ist nun mal ein Hauptauslass von Wärme. Und das will man ja verhindern, aber man muss eben selben oder zumindest in einem angemessenen Maße auch noch Dämmung auf die Wand, also an der Außenwand dann üblicherweise wahrscheinlich anbringen, oder?
Außendämmung ist immer baufisikalisch deutlich unkomplizierter als Innendämmung. Das geht auch, aber da muss man sich mehr Gedanken darum machen. Außendämmung, jetzt im Fall vom Fensteraustausch, wäre wirklich die Frage, dass man sich überlegt, was mache ich da an der Fensterleibung. Es muss nicht unbedingt eine Dämmung da sein, nur dann muss ich wirklich bewusst kontinuierlich auch über das Fenster lüften. Oder ich baue gleich eine Lüftungsanlage ein, vielleicht einfach nur eine Abluftanlage. Das kann das auch sehr gut beheben und hat zusätzlich noch den Nebeneffekt, dass man einfach eine bessere Raumluft hat.
Also man hat sozusagen mindestens zwei kritische Komponenten, nämlich man hat die Feuchtigkeit und man hat die Frischluft. Beides muss sichergestellt sein, dass es trocken genug ist, aber auch nicht zu trocken vielleicht. Und man will ja auch noch atmen, also braucht man irgendwie Frischluft. Und da steht ja beides jetzt erst mal dieser Idee der Dämmung entgegen.
Nein. Also Frischluft kommt nicht durch die Wand. Es gibt ja dieses Vorurteil, die Wand muss atmen können, aber dem ist nicht so. Sobald die Wand verputzt, ist sie luftdicht. Und deswegen resultiert der Luftaustausch, den man in einem Bestandsgebäude hat im Altbau, eigentlich immer entweder über die Fensterlüftung oder über Fugen. Und diese Lüftung über die Fugen, die hängt entscheidend davon ab, wie kalt es draußen ist. Wenn es draußen kälter ist als drinnen, gibt es da einen thermischen Antrieb und deswegen zieht es dann eben auch im Winter. Und der Wind spielt natürlich eine wichtige Rolle. Wenn der Wind stark weht, dann habe ich auch einen höheren Luftaustausch über diese Fugen. Das Problem ist, das kann man nicht wirklich beeinflussen. Also im Winter habe ich dann meistens zu viel Luftaustausch und in der Übergangszeit, wenn es draußen so 15 Grad ist Windstil, gar keinen. Und deswegen ist es auch für die Bewohner eigentlich ganz angenehm, wenn man noch eine Lüftungsanlage im Gebäude hat. Da braucht man sich nicht mehr darum zu kümmern. Es funktioniert einfach.
Also es wäre sozusagen bei einer Sanierung, ich bin jetzt immer noch bei diesem, ich verbessere etwas, ich verbessere den Bestand, also bessere Fenster, eine Außendämmung und dazu noch eine Lüftungsanlage. Und das ist dann erstmal schon auf dem richtigen Weg. Das ist schon mal so das Wesentliche, woran man denken muss.
Das sind zumindest mal die Hauptquellen oder die Hauptverlustzweige jetzt von Wärme. Und wenn man dann noch die oberste Geschossdecke oder das Dach dämmt, das kommt dann so ein bisschen aufs Gebäude an, ob das einfach oder aufwendig ist. Und unter der Kellerdecke, dann ist man schon fast fertig.
Aber vielleicht gehen wir mal weg von diesem Sanieren, was nicht so toll war und schauen wir doch mal, wenn man jetzt die Wahl hat. Man will jetzt ein Haus bauen, das soll ja vorkommen. Man hat den Wunsch, da möglichst wenig Langzeitgeld drin zu versenken. Also abgesehen von den Baukosten natürlich will man jetzt nicht, auch unabhängiger sein von den Energiekosten. Ein Argument ist natürlich, weniger Energie verbrauchen macht gutes Karma. Aber am Ende entscheidet ja auch nicht selten einfach nur der Geldbeutel. Wenn man jetzt so ein Passivhaus from scratch neu erdenkt, was gehört dazu? Was braucht man? Wie geht man da ran? Also wird sowas hier auch gemacht?
Wir planen keine Häuser, aber wir beraten Architekten.
Also ihr steht hier die ganze Zeit in Verbindung auch mit solchen Architekten, die Fragen haben etc. oder auch neue Ideen.
Ich denke mal, der Ansatz, wie man ein Passivhaus plant, ist jetzt nicht groß anders als bei konventionellen Gebäuden. Da steht erst mal das Raumkonzept im Vordergrund. Was brauche ich an Fläche? Welche Nutzung möchte ich darin unterbringen? Und dann sollte man sich natürlich schon auch Gedanken drum machen, wie erreiche ich jetzt meine Wärmedämmung? Ich kann natürlich genauso vorgehen, wie ich beim Altbau vorgehen würde. Ich habe eine ganz normale Wand, die diese statischen Lasten aufnimmt und die dämm ich dann von außen. Das wird häufig gemacht. Das führt natürlich dazu, dass ich unter Umständen mehr Kosten habe. Wenn ich mehr Dämmung aufbringe, ist es natürlich auch teurer. Aber es gibt auch die Variante, dass ich versuche, Konstruktionen zu entwickeln, die schon auf dieses Passivhaus hin optimiert sind. Das ist oft bei Holzhäusern so. Da habe ich dann eben eine Außenwandkonstruktion, die Statik trägt. Und gleichzeitig ist in dieser Ebene auch schon Dämmung vorhanden. Um die Wärmebrücken zu reduzieren, wird dann noch eine Außendämmung zum Beispiel aufgebracht. Aber dadurch habe ich einen deutlich schlankeren Wandaufbau und eben nicht mehrere Funktionen in dieser Außenwand hintereinander geschaltet, sondern ich habe es ein bisschen kombiniert. Beim Massivbau ist ein Beispiel, dass ich eben keine 36er oder 30er Außenwände baue und die dann noch mal von außen dämmen. Das wäre völliger Unfug, sondern dann nehme ich schlankere Materialien, sodass ich zum Beispiel nur 20 Zentimeter als statisches Gerüst brauche und packe da dann die Außenwanddämmung davor. Die nicht zwangsläufig jetzt irgendwie Polystyrol oder so ein künstliches Material sein muss. Das kann genauso gut Zellulosefaser sein, also Recyclingmaterial.
Aber auf welcher Basis wähle ich das jetzt aus? Also ich meine, wenn ich jetzt angenommen bin, ich bin jetzt so ein Architekt, der ich nicht bin. Und ich wollte jetzt halt so das optimale Passivhaus bauen. Das hängt ja dann auch erstmal davon ab, wo man es baut, oder?
Ja, es spielt sicherlich auch eine Rolle, ob ich jetzt einen völlig freistehenden Bauplatz habe, wo ich das Gebäude auch so orientieren kann, wie ich möchte. Oder ob es da einen Bebauungsplan gibt, der mir zum Beispiel vorschreibt, dass die Fürstlinie in Süd-Nord-Richtung orientiert ist. Und da kann ich dann zum Beispiel bei der Optimierung der Fensterflächen, also viele, nicht zu viele, aber ausreichend viele Fenster nach Süden oder Südwest, Süd-Ost. Und normalerweise weniger Fensterflächen dann nach Norden. Das hat oft auch Konsequenzen dann für die Anordnung der Räume im Gebäude. Packt man eher das Wohnzimmer nach Süden und Badezimmer nach Norden. Das spielt da natürlich mit Sicherheit mit rein. Wenn ich ein optimal ausgerichtetes Grundstück habe, dann ist es einfacher. Wenn ich einen Standard wie den Passivhaus-Standard erreichen will, wenn das Gebäude anders stehen muss, dann muss ich mich unter Umständen an anderen Stellen ein bisschen mehr anstrengen, um dieses Ziel zu erreichen.
Du hast ja gesagt, es gibt da viele Möglichkeiten. Man würde jetzt auch nicht erwarten, dass es da jetzt so einen goldenen Ansatz gibt und den muss man jetzt verfolgen. Aber was kommt denn jetzt noch dazu? Ich habe jetzt meine Raumplanung abgeschlossen, was weiß ich. Da soll jetzt eine Familie mit zwei Kindern wohnen. Es gibt entsprechend viele Räume. Baut man dann einen Keller oder lässt man das sein? Ist das relevant?
Das ist indirekt relevant. Das entscheidet eigentlich der Geldbeutel. Man braucht diese Kellerflächen. Es ist ein bisschen einfacher, wenn man auf den Keller verzichtet. Aber es gibt ganz viele Passivhäuser, die auch einen Keller haben. Es ist noch die Frage, ob es ein warmer Keller ist. Die Dämmung geht dann auch um den Keller rum. Man kann da vielleicht nicht so gut Kartoffeln drin lagern. Oder ist es ein kalter Keller? Dann muss die thermische Hülle zwischen dem Erdgeschoss und dem Keller verlaufen. Das macht die Sache ein bisschen aufwendiger. Aber auch dafür gibt es Lösungen.
Aber es ist einfacher, wenn man keinen Keller hat? Weil ein Keller generell schwierig zu bauen ist oder weil er schwierig zu isolieren ist?
Weil er schwierig zu isolieren ist.
Ah, weil es in der Erde ist und so. Bei mehr Feuchtigkeit etc. Ah, okay, verstehe. Aber es ist ein gelöstes Problem eigentlich.
Das ist dann wirklich eine Frage der Kosten.
Ja.
Und dann kommt natürlich noch die Lüftungsanlage dazu. Also das ist ja bei einem Passivhaus ganz entscheidend, dass ich dem Gebäude kontinuierlich frische Luft zuführe und die Abluft dann zum Beispiel aus Küche oder Bad absauge und die Wärme, die in dieser Luft noch drin enthalten ist, übertrage auf die Zuluft. Das ist aber nur eine Wärmeübertragung, keine Geruchsübertragung. Und auch normalerweise keine feuchte Übertragung. Das gibt es mittlerweile zwar auch, aber das ist noch nicht so verbreitet. Da ist einfach ein Wärmetauscher aus dünnen Metalllamellen, wo auf der einen Seite die Abluft rausströmt. Auf der anderen Seite kommt im Gegenstrom die frische Zuluft rein. Dadurch erwärmt sich die Zuluft und kommt dann mit mindestens 16 Grad ins Gebäude rein.
Das heißt, es ist die ganze Zeit eine Pumpe eigentlich am Arbeiten?
Nein, das waren jetzt einfach nur zwei kleine Ventilatoren, die Luft fischen.
Okay, das wollte ich auch sagen. Also ein Gebläse, was sozusagen Luft von außen ansaugt und schickt sie durch diese Stahlrippen durch, die quasi erwärmt werden von der Luft, die nach außen geschickt wird. Also die verbrauchte Luft geht permanent raus, aber auf dem Weg nach draußen lässt sie quasi die Wärme drin.
Richtig.
Und also wie viel Prozent dieser Wärme kann man an der Stelle entnehmen, dieser Luft? Also schafft man das?
Das schafft man natürlich nicht vollständig.
Also die kommen nicht mit Null Kelvin da raus, aber was hat man als Verwirkungsgrad und wie groß muss man sich diesen Apparat vorstellen?
Also für ein Passivhaus sollte das Gerät eine Rückwärmezahl haben, also ein Wirkungsgrad im Prinzip von 80 Prozent. Es gibt Geräte, die erreichen Wert deutlich über 90 Prozent, die sind dann größer. Denn dieser Wirkungsgrad hat auch was mit der Wärmetauscherfläche zu tun. Und wenn dieser Wärmetauscher größer wird, dann kann ich auch einen größeren Wirkungsgrad erreichen.
Was ist größer?
Ein kleines Gerät, das häufig eingesetzt wird, hat so die Größe von einem Umzugskarton vielleicht.
Okay, das ist ja noch relativ kompakt.
Genau, und das geht aber schon dann bis zu einer Höhe von einem Meter und einer Breite von 50-60 Zentimeter bei den großen guten Geräten, die dann eben auch öfters in Gebäude eingesetzt werden, wo genügend Platz ist. Wenn es eng ist, dann werden eben eher die Kompakten verwendet.
Das ist eine reine Preisfrage oder hat das auch was mit der Luftmenge zu tun, die da getauscht werden muss? Also umso größer das Haus, umso größer der Wärmetauscher?
Das auf alle Fälle auch, aber ich sage mal üblicherweise eine Wohnung, die hat so zwischen 70 und 150 Quadratmeter bei Häusern. Die werden heutzutage selten über 200 Quadratmeter haben. Da unterscheidet sich jetzt die Größe des Gerätes oder des Wärmetauschers nicht so besonders.
Und man hat in der Regel auch nur einen?
Ja.
Also dass man jetzt so mehrere kleine an verschiedenen Stellen macht, ist eigentlich Quatsch, bringt nichts.
Es gibt auch dieses Konzept, dass man in jedem Raum einen kleinen dezentralen Lüfter montiert und da ist dann noch ein Keramikkörper als Wärmetauscher drin und dann wird die Luft dann einmal 90 Sekunden lang im einen Raum angesaugt, strömt durch das Haus und auf der anderen Seite durch einen anderen solchen kleinen Lüfter strömt sie wieder raus. Nach 90 Sekunden wird das umgedreht und die Luft strömt wieder in die andere Richtung. So dass es immer einen dieser kleinen Wärmetauscher, dieser Keramikmaterialien in der Wand gibt, die sich aufwärmen und einen, der sich abkühlt. Dann wird das umgedreht, dann wird an der Stelle, wo jetzt ein warmer Wärmetauscher sitzt, die Luft wieder angesaugt und sie kann sich dann wieder erwärmen.
Was heißt in dem Moment, wo das Ding absaugt, wärmt sich diese Keramik auf?
Durch die Luft.
Und dann kommt die frische, kalte Luft und wird dadurch wieder warm reingeblasen?
Genau. Das Konzept ist jetzt allerdings nicht so optimal, denn es gibt ja auch Luft, die man jetzt nicht mit anderen Räumen vermischen will, zum Beispiel aus dem Bad oder aus der Küche. Und wenn man jetzt wirklich die Luft aus dem Bad ins Wohnzimmer bläst, das will man eigentlich nicht.
Verständlich.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen ein anderes Konzept, das man auch mögen muss.
Wo man so den Geruch auch mögen muss. Okay, verstehe. Eigentlich, wenn man immer frische Luft hat.
Ja, das ist eigentlich der Ansatz.
Aber das heißt natürlich, das Ding muss dann umso intensiver arbeiten können, umso kälter es draußen ist?
Nö, das läuft eigentlich relativ konstant durch.
Also die Wärmeleistung, wie sagt das so? Rückwärts?
Rückwärmezahl. Sag mal, Wirkungsgrad.
Der Wirkungsgrad ist sozusagen davon jetzt unbeeinflusst, wie groß der Temperaturunterschied ist.
Das hat schon auch einen Einfluss, aber jetzt keinen gravierenden. Und ich will natürlich diese Wärmerückgewinnung hauptsächlich im Winter haben. Darauf ist es ausgelegt. Und wenn ich jetzt in der Übergangszeit Teillast habe, weil es draußen nicht ganz so kalt ist, dann kann mein Wirkungsgrad ein bisschen ansteigen. Aber das ist jetzt nicht so entscheidend.
Aber es ist ja eigentlich auch ein extremer Komfortgewinn, den man da mit einem Passivhaus hat.
Ja, sehe ich eigentlich schon.
Weil man eigentlich immer frische Luft hat. Also dieses, oh mein Gott, ich müsste mal wieder lüften, das kennt man dann eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Das brauchen wir nicht. Und auch zum Beispiel im Schlafzimmer. Es gibt Leute, die haben im Schlafzimmer immer ein Fenster gekippt. Und wenn man das nicht will, weil es einem zu kalt wird, hatte man ein Problem. Man steht ja nicht alle zwei, drei Stunden auf, um mal kurz stoß zu lüften, damit wieder frische Luft drin ist. Und mit so einer mechanischen Lüftungsanlage kommt eben kontinuierlich frische Außenluft rein, vorerwärmt. Und das ist auch ein Komfortgewinn. Das muss man sozusagen zusätzlich zur Energieeinsparung auch mit anrechnen.
Ja, ist auch mehr so Staubfreiheit.
Ja.
Oder ist das jetzt schon zu viel erwartet?
Nee, also diese Lüftungsanlagen haben zusätzliche Filter, die eben die Außenluft reinigen. Und da gibt es unterschiedliche Filterqualitäten. Und das geht schon bis hin zu Pollenfiltern, die auch für Allergiker dann die Luft angenehmer machen im Gebäude.
Na ja, das ist natürlich auch noch so ein Aspekt. Nicht, dass man sich jetzt so gerade das Heuschnupfenproblem dann auch noch hinein importiert auf die ähnliche Basis. Okay, das heißt, es ist sogar besser als das normale Lüften, weil man eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur gefilterte Luft atmet. Und schön isoliert vom Rest der Welt.
Und dann auch noch schön warm.
Okay, also, haben wir es eigentlich schon? Also, ich meine, ist das sozusagen das A und O? Also, man richtet, man versucht das Haus im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten der baurechtlichen Vorschriften, bzw. wie gesagt so schön, die Planfeststellung, der Bauungsplan, was der vorsieht, versucht man alles erstmal so auszurichten, dass man Nord-Süd mit einplant, dass das, was eher kalt bleiben kann am Norden ist und da, wo man es gerne mollig warm hat, eher Richtung Süden zeigen lässt. Und dann entsprechende Glas-Frenster-Fronten, die ja dann im Prinzip auch eine Heizung sind.
Also diese Zornierung, also die Anordnung der Räume im Gebäude ist bei Wohngebäuden nicht so entscheidend. Aber trotz allem versucht man es einfach danach auszurichten, weil eben die Nutzung fordert, dass ich im Wohnzimmer eigentlich Sonne habe und nicht unbedingt im Schlafzimmer oder nicht so viel. Also energetisch ist das jetzt nicht so das Entscheidende.
Aber was ist denn, wenn man, ich meine, man hat vielleicht meistens das Problem, dass man es gerne wärmer hätte? Aber wenn jetzt ein richtig heißer Sommer daherkommt und die Sonne brüllt rein, und jetzt hat man auch noch alles nach Süden und viel Glasfronten etc., dann heizt sich ja sowas aus. Das ist ja so ein Dachwohnungsproblem. Da wo ich wohne in Berlin, da Prinzlauer Berg, da ist das ja so der totale Hype, irgendwie alle altbauten da oben noch irgendwie so ein Schnuffi-Dach oben draufzubauen. Und dann ziehen sie alle ein und dann kommt der erste Sommer. Hätte ich das mal nie getan. Wie arbeitet denn dann dieser Wärmetauscher? Kann der seine Funktion auch umdrehen und dann als Kühlschrank arbeiten? Oder funktioniert das nicht so?
Das funktioniert direkt nicht. Das könnte man mit einer Wärmepumpe realisieren. Aber ein wichtiger Aspekt jetzt im Sommer ist eigentlich, dass man verhindert, dass dann die Sonne durch die Fenster oben einstrahlt. Und das kann man zum Beispiel dadurch erreichen, dass man einfach Balkone oder Überstände direkt mit einplant, die so ausgerechnet sind, dass im Winter, wenn die Sonne tiefer steht, sie unter diesen Balkonen mit durchscheint in den Wohnraum rein. Und im Sommer oder in der Übergangszeit, wenn sie eben höher steht, verschattet dann der Balkon. Und dadurch ist eigentlich schon meiner Meinung nach der wichtigste Punkt erreicht, den man bei der Planung berücksichtigen muss, für diesen sommerlichen Wärmeschutz, dass eben die Sonne draußen bleibt. Ansonsten eine Alternative sind Jalousien, Vorhänge sind schlecht, denn Vorhänge sind meistens auf der Innenseite. Und dann ist die Sonne erstmal drin.
Ach so, okay, ja verstehe.
Also man sollte wirklich gucken, auf jeden Fall dafür sorgen, dass außen verschattet wird. Und dann kann so ein Passivhaus auch deutlich angenehmer und kühler sein als ein konventionelles Gebäude. Weil natürlich über die Scheiben und auch über die Wände es gut gedämmt ist. Das heißt, es verliert im Winter weniger Wärme nach draußen. Aber im Sommer, wenn es draußen wärmer ist, kommt auch weniger Wärme nach drinnen.
Die Isolierung geht ja in beide Richtungen.
Würde es nur, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel vergessen hat, die Schalusinen runterzumachen. Das Gebäude ist wirklich aufgeheizt. Dann muss man wirklich über Nachtkühlung die Temperatur wieder absenken. Aber das ist eigentlich nicht so viel anders als bei normalen Gebäuden. Das kenne ich auch aus dem Altbau.
Jetzt haben ja diese Passivhäuser keine Heizung. Also haben sie keine Heizung?
Sie haben Heizung.
Und ich finde es auch gar nicht so schlecht, wenn sie Heizung haben.
Ja, aber eigentlich brauchen sie ja keine, oder?
Richtig.
Wie muss man das sehen?
Also, man kann so ein Passivhaus über die Zuluft beheizen. Da ist nach der Wärmerückgewinnung noch so ein kleines Heizregister drin, das dann die Zuluft von 18 Grad auf 40 Grad erwärmt, um die benötigte Heizwärme ins Gebäude reinzubringen. Hat allerdings den Haken, dass ich dann die Lüftung nicht unabhängig von dem Heizwärmebedarf betreiben kann. Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sage, im Winter bin ich da, ich stelle meine Lüftung auf Grundstufe, einfach nur, dass das Gebäude weiter belüftet wird. Das würde dann aber dazu führen, wenn ich eine Zuluftheizung habe, dass ich auch weniger Heizwärme einbringen kann. Und deswegen muss man dann zum Beispiel bei einer reinen Zuluftheizung im Prinzip die Lüftung auch durchlaufen lassen. Man kann aber im Passivhaus genauso gut Heizkörper montieren, finde ich eigentlich fast auch besser. Man braucht nicht so viele und wenn dann nur ganz kleine. Dann sind Beheizung und Frischluftversorgung unabhängig voneinander.
Das heißt, okay, also der einfachste Weg ist, man baut, also eine Heizung wäre dann einfach elektrisch betrieben oder was?
Elektrisch betrieben wäre unschön.
Sondern man nimmt dann schon Gas oder was man auch sonst nehmen würde.
Das ist gar nicht so trivial bei Passivhäusern, weil sie so wenig Energie verbrauchen, dass so diese konventionellen Energieversorgungen, wie Gasanschluss eigentlich viel zu teuer sind. Allein die Anschlusskosten und die monatliche Grundgebühr von so einem Gasanschluss ist mehr als das, was man an Heizwärmebedarf hat. Also man braucht ja wirklich ganz kleine Heizleistungen.
Wenn man jetzt nicht explizit Gas haben will, um damit zu kochen zum Beispiel.
Genau, man braucht eine ganz kleine Heizleistung. Und jetzt so bei Einfamilienhäusern wird oft ein Wärmepumpen-Kompaktaggregat verwendet. Da ist dann dieses Luftungsgerät verbunden mit einer Fortluftwärmepumpe, also aus dieser Luft, die nach dem Wärmetausch eigentlich nach draußen geschickt wird, wird dann noch mal die restliche Wärme entzogen. Die wird dann also unter Außenlufttemperatur abgekühlt. Das ist im Prinzip das gleiche wie beim Kühlschrank, nur umgekehrt. Und mit dieser Wärme kann man dann das Gebäude beheizen, zum Beispiel über die Zuluft.
Aber dann heizt man doch immer noch nur mit der Energie, die schon drin ist im Haus.
Richtig.
Man muss ja erst mal irgendwie reinkommen. Ich meine, was ist, wenn das Haus kalt ist? So sagen wir mal, es ist Winter und alles wurde ausgeschaltet, noch mal Fenster aufgemacht und jetzt habe ich da irgendwie meine gediegenen Nullgrad im Haus. Was tue ich jetzt, um das Ding irgendwie warm zu kriegen?
Also ich würde empfehlen, es gar nicht so weit kommen zu lassen.
Ja, okay, aber nur für den Fall, das werden wir passieren. Stromausfall, was ist dann?
So ein Passivhaus kühlt nicht so schnell ab. Also das kann Wochen dauern, bis es wirklich bis auf Außentemperatur abgekühlt ist.
Wochen?
Wochen, ja. Weil es gibt ja immer noch diese Solarenergiegewinne. Dann, wenn sich jemand in dem Gebäude aufhält, dann gibt es die Abwärme der Personen. Das ist wirklich ein nennenswerter Teil auch bei so ein Passivhaus. Das wird auch in der Energiebilanz berücksichtigt.
Wie viele Personen sich daran aufhalten? Ich halte sie mit.
Genau, 80 Watt. Das ist gar nicht so wenig.
Echt, ich bin 80 Watt?
Vielleicht doch, 85.
Nicht mal treiben.
Okay. Und genauso natürlich die Abwärme von allen Elektrogeräten. Im Endeffekt wird die ganze elektrische Strom zu überwiegendem Teil am Schluss in Wärme umgewandelt. Und auch das ist ein ganz wichtiger Teil bei der Energiebilanz.
Stimmt, das habe ich noch gar nicht bedacht. Man betreibt ja auch Dinge. Man betreibt Computer und Kinder und all diese Sachen. Das heißt, im Normalfall, in einem Bewohnungsfall, hat man eigentlich am laufenden Meter irgendwo Heizquellen, die ausreichen, gemeinsam mit der Dämmung die Temperatur da zu halten, wo man sie haben möchte?
Ich sage mal, bis Außentemperaturen von 10 Grad, das ist das, was man normalerweise als Heizgrenze bei Passivhäusern festlegt, reicht im Prinzip. Die Abwärme von den Personen und von den Geräten aus. Und erst darunter muss dann entweder dieses Kompaktaggregat einspringen oder eine Gastherme. Also es gibt ja jetzt nicht nur freistehende Gebäude, sondern auch Mehrfamilienhäuser. Und die werden dann meistens schon mit Gas oder Öl oder sonst Fernwärme versorgt. Und dann kommt eben diese Restwärme, was relativ wenig ist, über diesen Fernwärmeanschluss zum Beispiel.
Fernwärme an einem Passivhaus?
Genau.
Macht das Sinn?
Wenn es ein einzelnes Haus ist, muss man sich darüber unterhalten. Aber jetzt in Siedlungen oder in Mehrfamilienhäusern auf alle Fälle.
Weil das, also Fernwärme ist ja noch mein Thema für sich.
Richtig.
Aber die Frage, was da für die Fernwärme sorgt. Ob es da sozusagen einfach zuzuführen war?
Also ich habe ja dann den großen Vorteil, ich brauche mich überhaupt nicht, um irgendeinen Heizkessel oder sonst was zu kümmern. Es ist beim Passivhaus, da haben wir noch gar nicht darüber gesprochen, gibt es auch Anforderungen an die Dichtheit des Gebäudes, damit diese Wärmerückwindung möglichst gut funktioniert. Da gibt es so einen Kennwert, der heißt N50, der sollte unter 0,6 liegen. Das kann man heutzutage relativ sicher erreichen. Bei Bestandsgebäuden muss man sich da ein bisschen mehr anstrengen.
Was drückt der aus, dieser Wert?
Der drückt aus, wie viel Luft aus dem Gebäude herausgefördert wird, wenn man einen Ventilator im Prinzip irgendwo einbaut und eine Druckdifferenz zwischen innen und außen von 50 Pascal aufbaut ist. Also ein Messzustand, ein künstliches Gleichgewicht, das man da herstellt. Aber damit kann man ganz gut bestimmen, ob das Gebäude Undichtigkeiten hat oder die Luft überwiegend über dieses Lüftungssystem geführt wird.
Das heißt, es muss nicht nur gedämmt sein im Sinne von es kommt keine Wärme raus, sondern es muss auch gedämmt sein im Sinne von es kommt auch wirklich keine Luft raus.
Um den Wirkungsgrad dieser wärmere Gewinnung zu garantieren. Sonst würde eben die Luft irgendwie da dran vorbei durch irgendwelche Ritzen ziehen. Das hat auch baufasikalische Gründe. Denn die warme Luft aus dem Inneren, die jetzt in so eine Konstruktion reinwandert, die kondensiert da aus die Feuchtigkeit, die da drin ist. Und kondensiert irgendwo in der Wand ist nicht so gut. Das will man auf jeden Fall verhindern. Und deswegen gibt es einfach auch diese baufysikalische Begründung, dass man möglichst dichte Gebäude haben möchte.
Wie spielt das jetzt zusammen noch mal mit dieser Heizwärmer?
Genau. Und jetzt kommen wir nämlich zu der Frage, wenn ich jetzt ein Gastherme zum Beispiel betreiben möchte, dann könnte ich die, weil mein Gebäude so dicht ist, nicht innerhalb, also nicht wie eine Gasetagenheizung betreiben.
Weil man ja die Abluft braucht von dem Verbrennen.
Die muss nach draußen gebracht werden, aber vor allem die Zuluft für die Verbrennung, die muss da reingeführt werden. Da gibt es zwar raumunabhängige Systeme, aber die Trennung dieses Verbrennungsprozesses von der Raumluft, die ist aufwendig. Da gibt es zwar Lösungen für, aber das versucht man zu vermeiden.
Verstehe. Und das geht dann genauso auch für eine Ölheizung.
Genau. Wenn man sie in den Keller packt, dann ist es wiederum relativ egal.
Aber ist Heizen mit Strom dann trotzdem so eine schlechte Idee? Abgesehen davon, dass man das über seine Geräte sowieso schon macht. Wenn jetzt der Wirkungsgrad dieses Wärmetauschers 90 Prozent beträgt, klingt jetzt erstmal viel. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das gar nicht viel. Aber ich gehe davon aus, das meiste, was ich an Wärme erzeuge, bleibt auch drin. Ist das dann nicht das Heizen mit Strom auf einmal wieder eine ökonomische Angelegenheit? Oder ist das immer noch so ineffektiv?
Das Problem ist natürlich die Stromerzeugung im Kraftwerk, dass die nur ungefähr ein Wirkungsgrad von 40 Prozent hat. Wir haben also von jeder Kilowattstunde, die jetzt zum Beispiel an Kohle in so ein Kraftwerk reingesteckt wird, kommen nur 40 Prozent als Strom raus und 60 Prozent werden in die Atmosphäre gepustet. Deswegen ist im Moment die Energiebilanz von Stromdirektheizung noch nicht so, dass man sagt, das möchte man jetzt wirklich umsetzen.
Dann gibt es das Prinzip dieser Kraft-Wärme-Kopplung bei Kraftwerken, wo dann auch die Abwärme des Produktionsprozesses für Strom gewonnen wird, oder zumindest nicht einfach abgeleitet wird. Und das ist dann wiederum die Quelle für Fernwärme. Das heißt, anstatt dass man Strom erzeugt und dabei Wärme verpuffen lässt, nur um diesen Strom dann auch wieder in Wärme zu verwandeln, nutzt man den ohnehin notwendigen Prozess dieser Stromerzeugung und die Wärme, die dabei schon abfällt, die nutzt man dann einfach auch direkt als Wärme.
Genau, das wäre am geschicktesten.
Fiffig. Wie verbreitet ist denn das eigentlich, die Kraft-Wärme-Kopplung? Ich habe immer viel darüber geredet, aber keine Ahnung, ob bei mir um die Ecke eins steht.
Das Problem ist, dass die heute üblichen Anlagen für Einfamilienhäuser eigentlich zu groß sind. Also die Geräte kosten auch einiges und man braucht eine Mindestwärme-Abnahme, damit sich der Betrieb von so einem Gerät überhaupt lohnt. Und oft wurde damit beworben, es wäre optimal für Leute, die zum Beispiel ein Schwimmbad zu Hause haben. Haben jetzt nicht so viele. Also ich würde mal sagen, bei Mehrfamilienhäusern ab einer Größe von fünf, sechs Wohneinheiten kann man sich das schon mal überlegen. Wenn man aber das Gebäude vorher gedämmt hat, wird es wieder ein bisschen schwieriger, denn die Heizzeit bei einem Passivhaus ist sehr kurz. Die fängt irgendwann Anfang November an, weil vorher hat man einfach noch gespeicherte Energie im Gebäude drin.
Selbst wenn es schon unter zehn Grad ist.
Genau. Und Mitte März kann man normalerweise die Heizung wieder ausmachen. Der Winter ist dann relativ schnell rum. Und wenn man nur eine kurze Zeit hat, wo man auch überhaupt Wärme braucht, dann ist das mit solchen dezentralen Geräten ein bisschen schwierig. Allerdings gibt es jetzt ja eine ganze Reihe Überlegungen, um auch unsere Stromerzeugung zu verbessern, Verstärkkraft-Wärme-Kupplung einzusetzen. Dann guckt man gar nicht so scharf auf die Wärmeabnahme im Gebäude, sondern sagt, okay, dann stellen wir einen großen Speicher nebendran. Und wenn das Gebäude jetzt die Wärme nicht braucht, dann schieben wir sie eben in diesen Speicher rein. Irgendwann werden sie schon auch mal duschen. Man hat ja nicht nur die Heizung, sondern auch warmen Wasserbedarf. Und dann verbrauchen sie die Wärme eben später. Und zum Beispiel der Energieversorger regelt dann diesen Motor für die Kraft-Wärme-Kopplung so, wie er es braucht, um seine Stromlast zu decken.
Genau, heißes Wasser. Darüber bin ich ja noch... Das habe ich heute jetzt komplett vergessen. Man braucht ja nicht nur so angenehme Temperaturen, sondern manchmal will man es halt auch heiß haben. Und jetzt nicht nur mit der Waschmaschine, die selber heizt, oder der Geschirrspüler, der selber heizt, sondern man will halt einfach heißes Wasser haben. Mir ist noch nicht so ganz klar geworden, was jetzt sozusagen die optimale Heizung ist. Also angenommen, ich habe keine Fernwärme. Also einfach irgendwo steht, wo das nicht gibt. Und Öl- und Gasheizung, also Verbrennungshalzung will ich nicht haben, weil das eine komplizierte Konstruktion ist. Und überhaupt ist das blöd, weil man braucht sie so wenig, dass es Quatsch ist und überhaupt will man das ja eh alle. Das ist ja eigentlich der Grund, warum man das alles baut, dass man das eben nicht mehr hat. Dann gibt es noch diese Super-Temperaturextraktoren, die dann aus dieser schon wärmegekoppelten Luft nochmal das Letzte rausholen. Reicht denn das jetzt, dass ich meinen zusätzlichen Heizbedarf im Winter damit schon decke? Oder gibt es jetzt noch irgendeine andere Wärmequelle? Oder muss man dann auf Strom gehen, um noch warm genug zu sein?
Also grundsätzlich jetzt für so ein Einfamilienhäuschen reicht die Restwärme, die in der Fortluft drin ist, die ich über ein Kompaktaggregat, also eine Wärmepumpe, da nochmal rausziehe, aus zur Beheizung.
Von heißem Wasser oder von der Wohnung?
Zur Beheizung der Wohnung. Und wenn es jetzt eben nicht die volle Heizleistung benötigt wird, wird eben auch das Warmwasser erwärmt. Aber genau wenn es jetzt draußen kalt ist, reicht es eben nicht aus. Und da wird üblicherweise sozusagen der einfachste Weg begangen, beschritten, und dann gibt es eben nochmal ein elektrisches Heizregister für die Warmwasserbereitung. Also ich würde eigentlich sagen, man sollte auf jeden Fall so ein Kompaktaggregat mit einer thermischen Solaranlage kombinieren. So, das ist der Einsatz von diesem elektrischen Heizstab zur Warmwasserbereitung, wenn eben die Wärmepumpe das alleine nicht schafft, auf sehr kurze Zeiten begrenzt wird. Aber da gibt es eine ganze Menge von Systemen und die funktionieren eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Man ist ja okay, wenn es jetzt wirklich nur darum geht, dass man jetzt mal schnell heißes Wasser braucht, dann nimmt man halt Elektro, weil das ist halt irgendwie nur eine sehr geringe Gesamtanteil zu einem Jahresanteil, also so für die Peaks nimmt man dann einfach Elektro. Aber man könnte auch einfach die nicht genutzte Zusatzwärme speichern, um permanent heißes Wasser vorzuhalten, in so einem Boiler dann oder wie?
Ja, das kommt eben ein bisschen darauf an, wie hoch der Warmwasserbedarf ist. Wenn man warmes Wasser über längere Zeit speichern will, müssen die Speicher schon verdammt groß werden. Und dadurch brauchen wir mehr Volumen auch, sie verlieren auch mehr Wärme. Das ist für ein Einfamilienhaus eigentlich jetzt nicht so das Optimale. Also man versucht dann schon, die solche Langzeitspeicher in Anführungszeichen, also über mehrere Tage bis vielleicht weniger Wochen, die werden eigentlich nur bei großen Gebäudekomplexen eingesetzt. In Einfamilienhäusern würde ich sagen, da hat man seinen Brauchwasserspeicher, der einerseits von der Wärmepumpe gespeist wird und andererseits von der Solaranlage.
Das heißt, eine Solaranlage ist nicht selten ein Teil eines Passivhauses?
Das kann ich jetzt gar nicht sagen, wie verbreitet das ist.
Das ist eine sinnvolle Ergänzung.
Das ist sehr sinnvoll meiner Meinung nach, gerade in Kombination mit einem Kompaktaggregat.
Und zwar eine solar-thermische Anlage, wo explizit die Wärme direkt, wo dann Wasser durch diese Sonnenpaneele durchläuft oder irgendein Transfermittel.
Ja, das ist Wasser mit Glykol als Frostschutzmittel.
Und das zieht dann eben direkt die Wärme. Also wird er erhitzt durch die Sonne. Und wo läuft das dann hin, diese Wärme? Also das läuft dann in solche Boiler.
Das ist dann ein separater Kreis. Da gibt es in diesem Warmwasserspeicher einen Wärmetauscher, der die Wärme aus dem Solarkreis auf das Trinkwasser überträgt. Und das Trinkwasser wird dann sozusagen gespeichert. Wenn ich dann meinen Warmwasserhahn aufdrehe, dann läuft das dann oben raus aus dem Speicher.
Und wohin wird das gespeichert? Hat man dann wirklich doch so einen Boiler?
Ja, also das ist dann irgendwie so ein 300 Liter Tank, ist so der Standardfall, der dann irgendwo noch neben der Wärmepumpe zum Beispiel steht.
Das heißt, mit dieser ganzen Technik, die man braucht, also Lüftung, klar, das sind dann erstmal so irgendwelche Rohre, also das Haus muss so gebaut sein, dass man überall hin Frischluft bringen kann. Also jeder Raum hat quasi einen Frischluftauslass und einen Absaugrohr, oder?
Es gibt eher so ein Durchströmungskonzept. Also Schlafzimmer, Wohnzimmer, die bekommen frische Luft. Und die Luft, die dann sozusagen aus dem Wohnzimmer da nicht mehr gebraucht wird, strömt dann zum Beispiel über den Flur zum Bad hin. Das heißt, es gibt die Frischluftzone, die Abluftzone, Bad und Küche, und dazwischen eben Überströmbereiche. Das heißt, es sollte eigentlich immer eine gerichtete Durchströmung des Gebäudes geben, damit eben auch Gerüche aus der Küche oder aus dem Bad nicht sich verbreiten können.
Das funktioniert eigentlich auch ganz gut. Das heißt, es hat mal schon wieder einen Komfortgewinn. In der Küche wird ja dann auch automatisch eine Dunstabzugshaube dadurch errichtet, kann man das so sagen?
Ja, nicht ganz. Also Dunstabzugshauben haben einen gigantischen Luftwechsel. Also, da wird ganz viel Luft umgewälzt. Das hat diese Lüftungsanlage nicht. Aber diese gerichtete Durchströmung kann es zumindest mal verhindern, dass sich die Gerüche dann in der Wohnung ausbreiten.
Aber man muss dann aber schon in diesem...
Genau. Man verwendet dann normalerweise Umlufthauben mit einem Aktivkohlefilter. Der zieht eben die Gerüche raus. Und dann wird eben die verbrauchte Luft über den Abluftstrang nach draußen geführt.
Das heißt dann aber auch im Umkehrschluss, das, was man ja eigentlich gerne hat in der Küche, nämlich eine Dunstabzugshaube, die wirklich direkt nach draußen geht, das ist dann schon wieder verboten, weil das würde ja das ganze Dichtheitsding etc. brechen.
Es würde das komplette Gleichgewicht zerstören.
Aber an der Stelle macht dann die Umlufthaube schon auch Sinn, weil die erst mal so das Schlimmste greift. Und so, ich weiß nicht, wie viel Luft verlässt so das Haus pro Zeiteinheit? Also was für eine Umweltsmenge?
Das sind so, je nach Hausgröße, 120, 150 Kubikmeter pro Stunde.
150 Kubikmeter pro Stunde? Das ist ja schon richtig viel. Oder kommt mir das jetzt nur viel vor?
Es entspricht einem …Ich meine, so viel lüftet man täglich nicht gerade. Es entspricht aber einem Luftwechsel von ungefähr 0,4 pro Stunde.
0,4 was?
0,4-facher Luftwechsel. Das heißt, ich habe ein bestimmtes Gebäudewolumen, sagen wir mal 400 Kubikmeter. Und davon werden jede Stunde 40 Prozent ausgetauscht.
0,4 im Sinne von 40 Prozent. Na, das schafft so eine Dunstabzugshaube nicht, ne?
Die hat eigentlich höhere Luftwechsel, aber sie zieht natürlich nur Luft ab. Die Frage ist natürlich, wo kommt die her? Da zieht man sich sozusagen wieder, wenn man die betreibt, durch irgendwelche Ritzen, kalte Außenluft in das Gebäude mit rein.
Stimmt, weil man ja auch so eine Unterdrucksituation dadurch erzeugt. Und dann zieht man einfach irgendwo her was. Ah ja, was ja in dem Passivhaus auch nicht so gut funktioniert. Okay, also ich bleib dabei. Das ist schon ein Komfortgewinn, weil man eigentlich generell innerhalb von, also wenn es von diesen 400 Kubikmetern Gesamtluftfläche in der Wohnung ausgeht und 150 Kubikmeter pro Stunde, kann man halt sagen, alle zweieinhalb Stunden ist jedes Partikel Luft mal erneuert worden.
Gerötig, ja, genau. Die Luft vermischt sich natürlich auch immer wieder mit der Alten, also die Frische, die reinkommt. Von daher, das nennt man dann Luftaustauschwirkungsgrad. Der ist dann nicht ganz bei eins. Das kommt eben auch so ein bisschen darauf an, wie diese gerichtete Strömung funktioniert. Aber wenn die perfekt funktionieren würde, dann würde es wirklich bedeuten, nach zweieinhalb Stunden.
Aber so Außen am Haus, Einlass und Auslass sind dann aber auch schon nochmal voneinander weit getrennt, oder sollten es sein?
Sollten es sein, schafft man nicht immer. Ist oft irgendwie baulich ein bisschen schwierig. Es gibt noch eine Sache, die gerade bei der Verwendung von so einem Kompaktaggregat sehr hilfreich ist. Das ist ein Erdreich-Wärmetauscher. Da wird eben die kalte Außenluft nicht direkt angesaugt, sondern erst in ein Rohr, das in der Erde verbuttelt ist. So 20, 40 Meter lang ist das oft auch in Schleifen unter der Bodenplatte. Und in der Erde erwärmt sich die Luft dann. Nicht viel, aber wenn ich zum Beispiel draußen Frost habe, dann kann ich meine Luft dann zumindest mal auf 8 oder 9 Grad vorher erwärmen.
Weil einfach so viel Wärme noch in dem Boden geschmackt wird?
Genau, diese Wärme führt dann eben dazu, dass eben auch dieses Kompaktaggregat besser funktioniert. Weil ansonsten, wenn ich mit Frosttemperaturen in das Gerät reingehe, bleibt natürlich weniger Wärme, die es dann hinten am Schluss noch abhumpen kann.
Wo bleibt die weniger Wärme?
Ein Großteil der Abluft wird auf die Zuluft übertragen. Wenn die Zuluft jetzt aber anstatt mit 10 Grad mit minus 10 Grad hereinkommt, dann die Fortluft, so nennt man das, das was eben nach dem Wärmetauscher nach draußen geblasen wird, hat dann zum Beispiel, wenn ich aus minus 10 Grad habe, habe ich eine Fortlufttemperatur von minus 5, minus 6 Grad. Da steckt natürlich weniger Energie drin, die dann die Wärmepumpe noch nutzen könnte, als wenn ich mit 10 Grad ansauge, die Wärme der Abluft wird übertragen und dann bleiben vielleicht noch 5 Grad übrig, die ich nach draußen blase bzw. bevor ich sie ausblase, schnappt sich die Wärmepumpe noch den Restenergie.
Also umso wärmer die angesaugte Frischluft ist, umso besser.
Genau. Das ist der höchste Wirkungsgrad dieses Komplexes.
Und das kann man dann nicht machen, dass man das für das Erd reicht für. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal so kompliziert, oder?
Das ist nicht kompliziert. Der größte Aufwand ist eigentlich, in der Bauphase da vorher noch mal die Gräben zu ziehen.
Wie tief liegt man das dann so? So ein Meter oder was?
Schon eher 1,50 Meter. Also schon recht tief.
Ah ja. Und dann muss es so 40, 50 Meter sich durch die Gegend schlängeln. Bis es auch wirklich eine Wirkung hat.
Genau, richtig. Man kann auch erkennen, dass dann so im Frühjahr, wenn die ganze oder viel der Wärme aus dem Erdreich jetzt an die Zuluft übertragen wurde, sinkt dann eben auch die Temperatur nach dem Erdreich-Wärmetauscher. Oder es macht nichts, weil im Frühjahr wird es da draußen wärmer. Dann bin ich nicht mehr so drauf angewiesen.
Und was mache ich, wenn ihr da jetzt so ein Kaninchen reinkrabbelt und meine Zuluft verstopft? Dann habe ich auch ein Problem.
Das sollten wir verhindern, vorher.
Ja, wie verhindern wir das denn? Das wäre auch ein Sicherheitsproblem.
Das kommt drauf an, ob es das eigene Kaninchen ist oder ein Fremdes. Nee, da sind immer spezielle Hauben und Gitter davor. Man möchte ja auch verhindern, dass jetzt die Luft zum Beispiel sehr viel Staub hat, wenn man das direkt über Erdreich ansaugt. Man hat einen Garten außenrum, der dann ja kein Grün hat. Das wäre zum Beispiel eine schlechte Stelle zu ansaugen.
Das heißt, man führt das eigentlich auch wieder hoch?
Man sollte es hochführen, macht man aber nicht. Dann hat man nämlich im Garten irgendwie so eine zwei Meter hohe Säule. Das sieht nicht immer schön aus.
Kann man doch am Haus auch entlang wieder hochführen, wie so eine Regengrüne oder nicht?
Ja, je nachdem, wie man diesen Wärmetauscher in der Erde unterkriegt, kann man das am Haus machen. Oft versucht man es aber, ein bisschen weg vom Haus zu platzieren. Das kommt eben darauf an, wie man den Wärmetauscher verlegen kann. Dann muss man sich was überlegen. Deswegen kommt dann eine Haube drauf mit einem Gitter, dass das Kaninchen nicht reinkommt und gegebenenfalls noch zusätzlicher Filter.
Das ist die einzige Quelle der Frischluft für das gesamte Haus, die dann aber auch strategisch überall verteilt wird. Wenn ich jetzt jemanden einen Streich spielen will und ich nehme eine Stinkbombe und leg die irgendwie auf dieses Gitter drauf, dann haben die ein Problem, oder? Das wollen wir mal eine kleine Sicherheitsanalyse machen. Single Point of Failure nennt man das in der Computertechnik. Von daher würde ich dann doch schon eher plädieren dafür, dass das Ding, da kann man ja noch eine Fahne dran machen und so, hat man auch gleich Nutzen draus gezogen. Das Rohr kann man ja quasi als Schornstein tarnen, nicht wahr? Da man ja eigentlich gar keinen mehr braucht, aber vielleicht aus romantischen Erwägungen vielleicht auch gerne einen hätte, könnte man aus dem Schornstein so ein Frischluftzuführungssystem bauen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Haben wir denn jetzt schon alle nennenswerten wesentlichen Komponenten, die zu diesem Gesamtgebilde Passivhaus beitragen, erwähnt? Oder würde es so alleine noch nicht funktionieren?
Funktionieren würde es so. Aber es gibt noch so einen Bereich, da sollte man auf jeden Fall einen Augenmerk darauf legen. Das ist nämlich der Stromverbrauch. Du hast ja vorhin gefragt, kann ich so ein Haus nicht auch direkt elektrisch beheizen? Wenn ich in meinem Gebäude zum Beispiel ganz viele Deckenfluder oder andere Geräte unterbringe, die viel Strom verbrauchen, dann brauche ich keine andere Heizung mehr. Also es ist überhaupt kein Problem, so ein Passivhaus mit meinem Stromverbrauch und dessen Abwärmen zu beheizen. Es ist aber wichtig, dass man sich auch Gedanken darum macht, wie man diesen Stromverbrauch weiter reduziert. Und das sind wir an einem Punkt, der jetzt in der Planung natürlich ganz schwer nur zu greifen ist, weil da spielt es auch eine Rolle, was die Eigentümer dann mitbringen, wenn sie einziehen, wie groß der Fernseher ist, eben wie viele Computer ständig laufen.
Wenn der Klassma-Bildschirm hängt, dann ist es halt schon vorbei.
Richtig. Also da sollte man dann auch darauf achten, jetzt nicht wegen der Energiebilanz, sondern weil es zum Gesamtkonzept eines möglichst energieeffizienten Gebäudes gehört.
Also, das ist jetzt die Frage, wie man darauf blickt. An der Stelle greift jetzt schon wieder der Begriff Niedrige Energiehaus, der eigentlich für die eigentliche Isolierung etc. und den Wärmeverbrauch wenig ausgesagt hat am Anfang. Aber wenn man das jetzt mal auf Passivhäuser wieder überträgt, ist das ja noch eher ein zusätzlicher Aspekt. Also wie reduziere ich meine Gesamtenergiekosten? Aber eben nicht nur die, die durch Wärme ausgelöst wird.
Das ist also wirklich eine Gesamtbetrachtung des Gebäudes während der Nutzung. Heizung beim Wasser, Strom.
Stand-by-Problematik. Viele Geräte sind immer an. Aber dann eben, obwohl sie eigentlich aus sind, oder ja genau, obwohl sie eigentlich aus sein sollten, sind sie trotzdem an, damit man sie leicht wieder einschalten kann. So was meinst du jetzt?
Genau. Oder eben auch den großen Blast im Fernseher.
Ist das hier auch ein Thema? Also ist das jetzt hier auch so Teil der Forschung?
Das ist allerdings ein schwieriges Thema, weil man natürlich da sozusagen an die Privatsphäre der Menschen dran gehen muss. Also wir haben da verschiedene Ansätze. Einerseits so die soziologisch-psychologische, dass man versucht, Menschen zu motivieren, sich Gedanken darum zu machen, wie sie zum Beispiel Energie nutzen. Denn die meisten Handlungen im täglichen Alltag laufen ja unbewusst ab. Und wenn es da zum Beispiel gelingt, dass es irgendwie selbstverständlich wird, dass ich zum Beispiel ein Gerät ausschalte, wenn ich den Raum verlasse, dann ist das jetzt keine Komforteinschränkung, oder wo sich jemand groß umstellen muss. Aber es kann zur Energieeinsparung beitragen. Wenn man natürlich jetzt mit der großen Energie- und Klimakeule kommt, da erreicht man unter Umständen weniger Leute. Aber auch so einen Ansatz muss man natürlich verfolgen, dass man zum Beispiel Aufklärungen betreibt. Was verbraucht jetzt mein Gerät oder meine Gerätschaften, die ich hier im Haus habe? Und brauche ich das überhaupt? Es gibt ja mittlerweile relativ viele Leute, die auch darüber klagen, wie hoch ihre Stromrechnungen sind. Und das ist oft einfach auch eine Unkenntnis dessen, was jetzt das einzelne Gerät braucht. Wenn ich denke, das macht ja nicht viel aus.
Da gibt es ja auch interessante, also ich habe aus den Nerdkreisen, die sich ja immer ganz gerne mit dem maximal Möglichen beschäftigen, auch jetzt gibt es zahlreiche Hobbyprojekte und auch schon weiterführende Projekte, die eben vor allem erst mal dieses universelle Strommonitoring ins Auge gefasst haben. Also dass man quasi alle Verbraucher, die man hat, möglichst so feingliedrig wie möglich separat misst von einem Computer, der permanent den Stromverbrauch quasi mitmisst, sodass man dann eben schön im Webbrowser sehen kann, so die Kurven, wie viel habe ich verbraucht. Das Minimum ist natürlich, dass man so an den Stromhauptanschluss rangeht und sieht, was zieht es überhaupt. Aber wenn man jetzt eben das mal wieder so denkt mit, ich baue mir mein Haus so, wie es mir gefällt, dann könnte man ja auch hergehen und sagen, mindestens jeder Raum, wenn nicht sogar noch feiner nach den einzelnen Verteilungskabeln, wie auch immer man das da gelegt hat, kann ich schon mal meinen Stromverbrauch messen, um überhaupt erstmal festzustellen, was weiß ich, wenn da auf einmal so ein Spike ist, hier viel Verbrauch, dass man sich überhaupt erstmal darüber Gedanken macht, so, oh ja, da steht ja noch diese Büchse, die brauche ich ja eigentlich gar nicht, die ist die ganze Zeit an. Oder irgendein Gerät hat vielleicht auch einen technischen Defekt und zieht auf einmal, was weiß ich, so einen Kühlschrank, der irgendwie durchdreht, ist aber irgendwie trotzdem leise, aber verbraucht trotzdem viel Strom, merkt man ja sonst erstmal nicht so ohne weiteres. Das wäre, glaube ich, schon mal so ein Ansatz bis hin zu so einer privaten Vollüberwachung, dass man jetzt sein ganzes Haus mit Bewegungsmeldern vollmacht und das Ganze mit einer entsprechenden Elektronik koppelt und sagt, ja, wenn ich jetzt in dem Raum so und so lange nicht gewesen bin, dann macht das Licht aus. Beziehungsweise hier habe ich jetzt mehrere Stromwege. Ich habe so eine Steckdosenleiste in der Wand, wo man normalerweise nur zwei Steckdosen hätte, hat man dann vielleicht fünf, wo man dann unterschiedliche Kategorien von Stromverbrauchern macht. Hier schließe ich alles an, was ich jederzeit automatisch abschalten kann. Ich stehe lampen oder so was. Hier schließe ich was an, wenn ich das Haus verlasse und sage, ich bin jetzt nicht da, was sich dann abschaltet. Vielleicht auch Sachen, die man sonst lieber auf Stand-by hat. Und dann noch so eine Steckdose mit, hier wird jetzt mal gar nichts automatisch geregelt, weil hier ist irgendwie ein lebenskritisches Element. Wenn man da medizinische Apparate zu Hause hat, zur Betreuung von jemandem oder so, dann kann man das ja nicht automatisch abgeschaltet lassen. So was schon mal gesehen?
Ja, wir hatten jetzt auch ein Projekt, wo wir das sozusagen in der Low-Tech-Variante umgesetzt haben. Das waren Mietwohnungen, also wir wussten gar nicht, was jetzt für Mieter da einziehen. Aber im Wohnzimmer waren alle Steckdosen, die in dem Bereich, wo Kabelanschluss, Netzwerkanschluss, Telefonanschluss sind, also wo man von ausgehen kann, da wird mal ziemlich viel Unterhaltungselektronik stehen. Die konnte man über einen zentralen Schalter am Ausgang des Wohnzimmers dann auf einen Schlag ausschalten. Das war sozusagen die Variante dessen, was du gesagt hast, nur mit einem einzigen Schalter. Und ich bin mal gespannt, werden die Mieter auch befragen, wie denn so eine einfache Variante angenommen wird. Denn wenn jemand sich schon mit dem Thema beschäftigt hat und Interesse gezeigt hat, dann ist es einfach, auch Einsparungen zu erreichen. Wenn aber jetzt jemand sich überhaupt nicht damit beschäftigen will, wie kriegt man den jetzt dazu? Nicht, dass man ihn, ohne dass man ihn gängelt, sondern man möchte einfach, dass er Dinge, die er nicht braucht, auf jeden Fall einfach abschalten kann.
Da muss ein Belohnungssystem dabei sein. So eine tägliche E-Mail, wie viel Geld man gespart hat, durch das Ausscheiden wäre vielleicht ganz hilfreich.
Wir sind jetzt auch gerade in Planung für ein neues Projekt, ein Passivhaus mit Energiegewinn, das also in der Bilanz mehr erzeugen soll als es verbraucht. Damit das funktioniert, ist es ganz wichtig, eben auch diesen Haushaltsstromverbrauch runterzukriegen. Genau da müssen wir überlegen, wie wir diesen Mietern ihren Verbrauch visualisieren können.
Was das Haus soll mehr Energie erzeugen als es verbraucht. Wie erzeugt das denn?
Das funktioniert dann einerseits über große Photovoltaikflächen. Zusätzlich wird es aber auch noch eine Kraft-Wärme-Kopplung geben, die die Wärme erzeugt und gleichzeitig auch noch mal Strom. Das ist aber gerade bei Mehrfamilienhäusern ziemlich schwierig, weil das Haus selber auch zum Kraftwerk wird. Genau.
Auf Basis von was? Also Kraft-Wärme-Kopplungen?
Mit regenerativen Energien. Dass überhaupt keine fossile Energie mehr verbraucht wird. Das hat dann zwar noch einen Anschluss an das öffentliche Stromnetz. Also das ist nicht energieautark.
Aber es kann auch einspeisen.
Und das brauchen wir auch, weil es gibt ja Phasen, wo man mehr erzeugt, gerade im Sommer über die Voltaik, als man verbraucht. Aber trotzdem ist natürlich die Frage, wie viel Dachfläche habe ich zum Beispiel im Verhältnis zu meiner Wohnfläche? Bei einem Einfamilienhaus geht das noch. Es gibt ja jetzt auch ganz viele Modellprojekte. Zum Beispiel dieses Solar-Decathlon-Gebäude. Da hat ja die TU Darmstadt 2007 und 2009 in Washington einen Wettbewerb gewonnen mit einem Haus, das neben vielen anderen Eigenschaften eben auch mehr Energie erzeugt, als es verbraucht. Und das hat jetzt auch so eingeschlagen, das könnte man sozusagen noch in diese geschichtliche Entwicklung, die wir anfangs hatten, noch anschließen, dass dieses Thema Nullenergie oder mehr Energie, als man selbst verbraucht, immer mehr diskutiert wird. Es gibt immer mehr Ansätze. Gestern habe ich gesehen, hat auch das Bauministerium mit der Deutschen Energieagentur wieder einen Wettbewerb ausgeschrieben für Häuslebauer und Planer, die Gebäude errichten wollen, die in ihrer Energiebilanz halbwegs ausgeglichen sind oder eben sogar mehr erzeugen wollen.
Das heißt, man verdient am Ende sogar noch Geld damit, dass man wohnt?
Ja, das wäre sozusagen das Ziel.
Wenn man sich das mal konsequent zu Ende denkt, wo es wahrscheinlich noch hakt, ist einfach, dass die Netze dafür nicht geeignet sind. Also so dieses ganze Dezentrale, wir speisen wieder Strom ein. Ich weiß, das ist jetzt auch nur im Ansatz. Ich muss auch unbedingt noch mal eine Sendung zu Solartechniken machen. Aber das ist ja so eine der primären Quellen, dadurch, dass hier so viel Photovoltaik installiert wird. Und ich glaube, in Deutschland sind das schon absurde Zahlen mit immer noch extremen Wachstum. Es entsteht einfach so viel Wiedereinspeisungsbedarf, der aber von der Netzinfrastruktur so gar nicht entgegengenommen werden kann, weil einfach die Netze eben für eine zentralisierte Verteilung in eine Richtung, so eine unidirektionale Verbreitung ausgelegt sind.
Wobei ich glaube, das größte Problem ist da eigentlich eher die Windkraft, weil die oft in ländlichen Gebieten oder auf hoher See aufgebaut wird. Photovoltaik, wenn sie jetzt in Städten eingesetzt wird, erzeugt ja eigentlich die Energie genau dort, wo auch die höchsten Verbraucher sind. Da werden wir sicherlich auch irgendwann an einen Punkt ankommen, wo die Netze nicht mehr wirklich ausreichen. Aber ich glaube im Moment ist eben diese dezentrale Erzeugung genau dort, wo man eben auch braucht. Und auch das Einspeisen des Überschusses in städtischen Regionen oder im Dorf selbst ist jetzt noch nicht so das Problem. Aber irgendwann wird das natürlich kommen.
Aber die zukünftige Stadt kann man sich eigentlich schon viel mehr als so einen Energieverbund von einzelnen Verbrauchs- und Erzeugungszellen vorstellen. Wo Überschüsse automatisch möglichst lokal, auch mit geringen Verlusten natürlich, durch geringere Übertragungswege, einfach weitergereicht werden. Also nicht nur ich heize für meinen Nachbarn mit, weil er irgendwie über mir ist und die ganze Wärme abkriegt, sondern dass eben tatsächlich durch einen Überschuss, den ich gerade selbst nicht verbrauchen kann, weil ich klug genug war, alle Verbraucher abzuschalten und mich trotzdem wohlfühle, aber nebenan, wo halt die Waschmaschine anläuft, wird dann dieser Strom auch gleich zum Einsatz.
Genau.
Ist es nicht auch generell einfacher, wenn man jetzt so eine Siedlung von Passivhäusern hat, da den Bedarf untereinander auszutauschen?
Ja, also es gibt im Moment auch ganz viele Überlegungen, um solche Null-Emissionsstädte oder Stadtteile zu entwickeln. Da gibt es jetzt noch nicht so viele konkrete Beispiele. Null-Energie, Bio-Dörfer oder sowas, das gibt es schon. Aber das ist sicherlich jetzt, zumindest bei Neubauten, das Ziel der Wahl, wenn ich jetzt ein neues Baugebiet ausweise. Da spielt natürlich irgendwann auch der Verkehr mit rein. Wir Techniker haben natürlich oft den Ansatz, dass wir die ganze Sache, wenn wir das eine im Griff haben, den nächsten Einflussfaktor auch mit berücksichtigen. In dem Fall haben wir super Möglichkeiten, den Heizungsbedarf zu reduzieren. Beim Wasser gibt es mit der Solartechnik auch einiges. Strom, na gut, da wüssten wir, wie es geht. Da müssen wir die Menschen noch mitnehmen. Aber Verkehr, das ist natürlich ganz schwierig, gerade in Deutschland alternative Konzepte vorzuschlagen und umzusetzen. Da gibt es ja jetzt diesen Hype um die Elektroautos. Da müssen wir einfach mal gucken. Vielleicht ist das ein Ansatz, ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Oder vielleicht doch wieder den Tante-Emma-Laden vollautomatisieren und wieder zurückholen, damit man nicht die ganze Zeit mit dem Auto zum Einkaufen fahren muss. Okay, ich sehe schon ein anderes Thema. Haben wir noch etwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen? Vielleicht zum Abschluss. Wenn jetzt jemand, der hier vielleicht auch zuhört, gerade so mit dem Gedanken spielt, ich könnte mir ja mal ein Haus bauen, soll ja vorkommen. Und man denkt so, naja, warum nicht gleich ein Passivhaus? Da mache ich noch einen Markt mit. Wie geht man da am besten ran? Also gibt es da so Beratungsstellen? Was ist so die beste Quelle für Informationen, um sich da schlau zu machen? Man muss ja auch einen Architekten finden. Man muss ja auch irgendwie wissen, was für Programme gibt, Siedlungen oder so.
Also man sollte auf jeden Fall den Architekten dann auch fragen, ob er schon Erfahrung mit Passivhäusern hat. Es ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen unfair, allen denjenigen, die jetzt erst einsteigen. Aber es hat sich schon gezeigt, wenn man selbst jetzt nicht so viel Know-how mitbringt, muss man sich eben auf den Architekten verlassen. Es gibt ganz viele, die sehr tief in der Thematik drinstehen und sehr gute Häuser bauen. Und da gibt es Datenbanken, es gibt Informationskreis, Passivhaus, da kann man auch Planer nachschlagen. Aber ich glaube, viel hilft einfach auch, rumfragen. Es gibt auch einen Tag des Passivhauses im November, da kann man sich Häuser angucken und auch mit den Leuten sprechen, die in so einem Gebäude leben. Man kann selbst mal für eine Stunde eine Erfahrung machen, was für ein Eindruck jetzt voll ist.
Wo gibt es diesen Tag?
Der ist in ganz Deutschland. Es öffnen Hausbesitzer ihre Wohnungstüren.
Ist in Deutschland das Pionierland für Passivhäuser oder gibt es andere Länder, die ja schon weiter sind?
Die Entwicklung hat in Deutschland angefangen, aber z.B. Österreich hat da mit ganz großen Schritten nachgezogen. Ich weiß es nicht, ob die uns da schon überholt haben. Auf jeden Fall sind sie da ziemlich auf einer Höhe mit uns. Schweiz hat so ein bisschen anderes Konzept. Die nennen das Minergie P. Minergie war im Prinzip das Niedrigenergiehaus in der Schweiz. Dann haben sie noch einen P für Passivhaus hintendran gehängt. Das geht auch in die Richtung. In anderen Ländern tun sich noch ein bisschen schwer. Aber es gibt da schon eine sehr große und aktive Bewegung, um das auch in anderen Klimazonen zu etablieren. Denn z.B. in Italien, Süditalien, muss ich mir vielleicht gar nicht so viel Gedanken um den Heizwärmebedarf machen. Ich muss mir aber vielleicht mehr Gedanken darum machen, wie ich das Gebäude im Sommer kühl kriege, ohne jetzt mit viel elektrischem Energieaufwand zu kühlen.
Das Problem mit den ganzen Klimaanlagen, die man in den südlichen Ländern immer wieder sieht, ist ja auch krass. Das ist jetzt sozusagen das Ganze nochmal umgedreht hier. Das können wir jetzt ja nicht mehr unter. War da jetzt schon so ein konkreter Tipp dabei, also Informationskreis?
Passivhaus.
Was ist das? Das ist so eine Informations...
Da gibt es eine Internetseite, da kann man ja vielleicht einen Link hinsetzen.
Genau, ich würde das nämlich jetzt hier gerade nicht so auf Anhieb... Ja, das ist nicht ganz dramatisches Vergessen haben.
Man könnte noch ganz viel über die Null- und Plus-Energiehäuser reden, aber ich glaube, das würde die Sendung dann sprengen.
Null und Plus? Hatten wir die nicht schon?
Aber nur kurz angerissen.
Das sind die, die jetzt mehr Strom, die noch Strom wieder reinholen.
Denn so viel vielleicht noch. Es gibt jetzt eine neue EU-Richtlinie zur Gesamtenergieeffizienz von Gebäuden, die vorschreibt, dass ab 2021 alle Neubauten in der Europäischen Union fast Null-Energiehäuser sind. Und das ist natürlich, das sind zehn Jahren, geht das los. Und das ist natürlich jetzt für alle Beteiligten ein ziemlicher Motivationsschub für die einen, für die anderen sagen eher, oh Gott, wie sollen wir das denn überhaupt erreichen?
Was heißt denn fast Null?
Das ist zum Beispiel eine der spannenden Fragen. Das ist jetzt von Seiten der EU nicht festgelegt worden, sondern das können die nationalen Regierungen dann definieren. Wobei die EU schon auch draufguckt, dass die Standards nicht zulasch gewählt werden.
Irgendeine Zahl müssen sie ja genannt haben.
Nein, das steht nicht drin.
Da kann man ja viel behaupten. Na ja, wir machen mal so 60 Prozent.
Also da gibt es noch überhaupt keine konkreten Anhaltspunkte.
Aber was ist deine Erwartung, was das so bedeuten würde in Deutschland? Vermutlich, also es gibt ja dieses, ich habe mir den Begriff vergessen, wie heißt das?
KfW 40 Haus.
KfW 40, das war ja auch in meiner letzten Sendung. Also es war ein KfW 60. Mittlerweile ist glaube ich KfW 40 eher schon so der Standard. Das heißt ja nur noch 40 Prozent dieser theoretischen 100-Prozent-Energie.
In dem Fall nicht. Das ist ein bisschen verwirrend in der Namensgebung. KfW 40 heißt, dass es das Gebäude 40 Kilowattstunden primär Energie verbraucht.
Das war eine absolute Zahl.
Genau. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das schon in diese Richtung läuft. Also irgendwie so um die 50 Kilowattstunden Primärenergie. Passivhäuser liegen da noch ein bisschen runter, aber auch nicht so viel. Die spannende Nebenbedingung bei dieser EU-Richtlinie ist jetzt aber, dass auch drinsteht, dass die Gebäude überwiegend oder zum großen Teil diese Energie, diese Verbrauchen am Gebäude selbst erzeugen müssen. Und zwar regenerativ. Also es geht da nicht mit einem Erdgas-Blockheizkraftwerk, sondern es muss regenerative Energie eingesetzt werden.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt, man darf schon mehr Energie verbrauchen, aber man muss sie dann auch selber erzeugen mit regenerativen Quellen, sprich Solar, Paneele etc. oder ein eigenes Vigrat noch im Hinterhaus.
Und ich denke mal, das wird auch in den nächsten 10, 15 Jahren eine ziemliche Umwälzung geben, jetzt auch im Planungsprozess, weil es nicht mehr ausreichen wird, sich nur die Gebäudehülle anzugucken, sondern man muss sich auch Gedanken um Energieerzeugungen machen.
Das heißt, diese Vision mit, wir werden alle unser eigenes Atomkraftwerk, das ist eigentlich... Das steht an. Das ist das nächste Thema. Man weiß ja schon, worüber ich in der nächsten Sendung reden werde. Ja, Marc, das war alles sehr aufschlussreich. Wir machen jetzt hier trotzdem mal einen Punkt. Ich muss nämlich auch noch einen zukriegen, ohne das jetzt hier voreilig abschließen zu wollen. Aber ich denke, das Thema Passivhaus haben wir jetzt erst mal ganz gut eingepackt. Ich bin gespannt auf die Fragen, die da kommen werden. Ich hoffe, du schaust noch mal in die Kommentare rein. Dann wird sicherlich das eine oder andere zu beantworten sein. Naja, und wenn es euch zwickt und zwackt, dann werde ich das Thema ja auch gerne noch vertiefen. Ich denke, diese ganze Gebäudetechnik etc., da ist noch eine Menge zu holen. Und wenn ihr tolle Projekte kennt hier zur Stromüberwachung, was wir hier auch schon angerissen haben, ich weiß, dass es da einige Projekte gibt. Ich kann gerade aus dem Kopf nichts nennen, aber da wird an einigen gebastelt. Und ich denke, das ist für jeden auch mal so zuhause auch ein eigenes Aha-Moment, wenn man sowas dann erst mal aufgebaut hat, zu sehen, so, oh, da blutet es aber ordentlich Strom. Da dann vielleicht auch mal was dagegen zu tun. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe nun 180. Und wie immer, hier geht es bald weiter.